hello everybody happy Tuesday December
13th
at the very edge of 2022.
what a year it's been
and uh we're almost through it but
welcome guys everybody
beautiful winter day
a little bit Breezy
a little bit a little bit frigid but we
love that about winter don't we folks
yeah
um today's episode is sponsored by
PayPal honey who we love so much thank
you
and um
by the way this Friday everyone's been
asking so you know the Year's been going
by fast this Friday is our world famous
highly anticipated sound bite Olympics
[Applause]
yes yes
I am so excited for this year's
soundbite Olympics it is going to be a
absolute Clash of Titans uh there are so
many great entries you know from from uh
from uh I can't remember a single one
though
oh I think fousey a gay but that's so
funny because it's not from this year
but it's popular it's here yeah popular
this year so it qualifies I am a Muslim
I am Jewish I am black I am gay
yes I felt ugly ugly felt gays yes yes
uh can I can I make my prediction for
guys taking the gold yeah there's only
one
possible answer
what are we going to do about it that
yeah I mean it was Howie's year it's
Howie's year it's how his year what do
we do about it what do we do about it it
was it was Howie's year but you never
know you never know you know anything
can happen in the sound bite Olympics
and you might get two CL two you know
great sound bites that go head ahead in
the big top of the bracket and then you
just never know are you separate how we
sound bites are you doing my friend Neil
bent over and then it's all what do we
do I think it's it's the whole package
yeah yeah
yeah
hmm I'm predicting a wild card Victory
this year with a Flocka
Flocka I I think Flocka should be with
help I don't think we should add fly no
flop why
because I love Zach and I want her uh
okay Zach will probably quit if it
doesn't bother me so you think
that you first of all you think Flocka
can win
absolutely
I think it's gonna go the distance dude
so you think flakka can win in that it
would crush Zach
not crushing but you know he's I he's
the sound God I think he deserves for
you know someone is support me Kim
Zach I love you man but Flocka doesn't
have a I mean listen I love the Flocka
but you're talking about matching it up
against you just said anything could
happen it could be a clash of the time
not that I look at Chad right now I'm
seeing Flocka's Spock is in the chat
I've seen a lot of you know what uh
another Wild Card 1 600 DPI yeah [ __ ]
that bro it's so it's so and you never
know what happens right because last
year at five percent won and we were we
didn't get to use it all year long
yeah
five percent I'm there
and maybe it's time we bring it back
that's uh sure we can do that there's
been enough time maybe we just don't
build on it the problem was that
whenever I heard it I would build on it
we'll keep it a rarity catch and release
10.
five percent difference is astronomical
that was it's been a long time though
you know
well that's exciting I'm I'm just pumped
for that you know
um today's Tuesday usually we're not
live on Tuesday as you guys know but
yesterday me and over the weekend me and
Ila went
to um
Big Sir for her birthday and we came
back yesterday so
yeah and she is 35 guys so of course she
is you wouldn't dare no she's 35.
she might even be 34 or 33. I'm not sure
all of a sudden I'm like robbing the
cradle there's a two and a half year
difference between opposite direction
I'm 50. she's 20. happy 19th birthday
she's accomplished so much at such a
young age it's unbelievable no she was
19 when I met her just to be just to be
talking
um I was 21 she was 19. just to be
totally clear on that not not
inappropriate age cap hold on two-year
age Gap
five
[Music]
stop it's not funny [ __ ] 20 something
year old girl this didn't come about me
I'm we're here to celebrate
get the stop
we're here to celebrate Ila whose
birthday was yesterday congratulations
yeah we had a great trip up in Big Sur
so we moved the Monday episode of
Tuesday which is why we're here live
here today
um also a little bit live
right very loud
very aggressive I felt that yeah and
also just to note
today I usually do the members only
podcasts you next Tuesday I just there's
no way for me to make it work this week
guys I'm sorry about that you know we're
having a full show today hold on where's
my you want me to stream for five hours
today would that make you guys Happy
where's my well I can't both of our kids
are sick too
okay we'll stop the booing because
I have other good news which is that
members rejoice
oh you didn't even hear me out yet
members rejoiced because over the break
I will continue see you next Tuesday
podcast for members every Tuesday be
there members Rejoice rejoice
yes so no complaining with peace and
love please no complaining thank you
thank you
get your [ __ ] ass up and work
thank you yeah yeah yeah yeah to me is
that she's mad at me or she does no
she's mad it seems like nobody wants to
work these days I said I'm gonna work on
my break what more do you want where's
the trunk okay fine close close the
trunk damn
so sassy did you notice I was trying to
watch the Kardashians I just can't get
into that show I know a lot of people
love it and let me tell you why
I don't root for any of them they're all
like way richer than they deserve way
more successful than deserve they're not
funny or charismatic or charming in my
opinion when I watch it I don't I'm not
real it's not good I don't say I'm sorry
I know everyone loves that show I like
the [ __ ] Housewives because like
[ __ ] I guess I hate them all too
now what but at least they're like they
have like their lives are [ __ ] up so
like you can Revel in the fact that
your life isn't as [ __ ] up as theirs
you don't think Kris Jenner is funny
I guess I haven't watched it enough
there was an episode in the new season
where she and Chloe get super high
and that was a really good episode I
recommend it okay you are wrong
yeah well I don't know but the point is
what is the point why did I bring that
up
I don't know
that was just kind of out of left field
were you were trying to watch it over
the weekend I'm trying to make a point
when you when you get away or something
what no we were yeah we were watching we
tried watching it right I was going
somewhere with it
completely
derailed my thoughts here all right well
but so what uh well there is a problem
the problem is
who's been leaving the K-Cups is that
what they're called yeah
the [ __ ] K-Cup pods all over the damn
place we got the coffee machine
can we get a picture of the coffee
machine and where the K-Cups have been
left yes here I can do I'll do a live
feed for my phone now before we somebody
confess up before we even get go to this
length we'll do it live how did I know
that nobody was going to own this
because no one does
nobody knows that's because no one ever
messes up
well the last time when someone was
leaving shits on the floor nobody even
Fester up to that
yeah we're showing it yes so show show
the scene of the crime
and show how close the trash can is too
yeah yeah show the trash can
mm-hmm
that's very close in fact if you want to
throw it in the recyclable you don't
even have to lift the lid you want to
show an example of throwing it in the
recyclable Dan it's way easier to throw
in there yeah yeah yeah yeah so look at
this you just dropped that [ __ ]
are you allowed to recycle those things
who cares you're supposed to actually
it's all trash it's all trash the
recycling is a is a [ __ ] giant scam
I'm sorry to say it is it is it like it
it all goes in the same hole in the
Earth
in reality
go ahead you guys got scammed that's
what I think that's right it's not all a
scam but I just heard a report like a
week or two ago about plastic
specifically and yeah about 90 of uh
plastic that you throw in recycling just
winds up in the landfill I think the
only thing that is actually truly
recyclable is like paper waste paper and
aluminum and aluminum yeah but I don't
know I don't know why that's real I
don't even know why they pretend like
the other [ __ ] like just throw that out
and recycle the good [ __ ] Bella Simmons
has already donated a hundred subbies
[Applause]
of you
happy birthday Bella
oh Bella Simmons yeah
by the way there's a way
that you guys if you click top there's a
way you have to enable to accept gifts
uh yeah and I think you can only do it
if you are watching on desktop too I
don't think it works on the
um
mobile
thank you so much yeah so
so has this been an ongoing issue Dan
the K-Cup I've been noticing at the last
I don't know last couple weeks it's a
kind of a recent development so so did
you found two there this morning just
not just like just before we started the
show yeah so there's 2K cups that were
left there now does anybody before we
start investigating this just come out
all will be forgiven I won't even I
won't even roast you like the coffee
beans that uh you shamelessly left on
the on the table
um does anybody want to just come out
and say it
wow
crickets you know what I'm gonna admit
too
not that but I do leave the K-Cups in
the dispenser sometimes
what I like make my coffee and I walk
you forget yeah is that forgivable Dan
it's shame it's shameful it's like if
everybody does that then everybody's
just throwing away the previous person's
K-Cup so everybody's still doing their
Duty what I have noticed is that there's
always a K-Cup in there that I throw out
in the trash right so you're paying it
forward right I'm paying a neutral I
guess
so let's let's start ruling people out
Dan because nobody's fessing up to this
and well I'm gonna rule myself out
because I would never do something so
[ __ ] monster that's what a guilty
person would say no [ __ ] no I'm really
oh I'm the one bringing this to the
table sounds pretty guilty to me but
okay well I have a theory Zach
if we want to just get to that bring it
up and by the way it's fine
not at all it is you no that's [ __ ] up
I'll tell you why because I grew up with
someone that did that and I found that
to be okay okay everybody calm down I we
need we need to keep this under order
okay okay let's start here who drinks
coffee out of the k thing me right here
dude just be honest we got Zach we got
Dan
cam can't is that it
is
that's it there's just for you
[ __ ]
now Dan I'm a rollout
thank you Lena you wouldn't do that
would you
yeah
no she's a wild card though she is a
little bit Wild Card that'd be so funny
it's like it's not Lena dude it's you
exactly there's no other option it's not
me I swear to God baby baby doesn't
drink the coffee he said besides that
you guys know I'm annoyingly clean yeah
yeah that's not look at my look at my
look at my wires on my desk it's like
retentive about oh yeah can says he
admits to leaving his cup in the coffee
yeah I do that I do that sometimes but I
don't leave it on the thing right there
is Cam's admission a way of throwing us
off or is it him trying to
just open his palms to us and say look
how honest I am I I think it him saying
that I could have possibly done it no no
no no no no no no no I would never do
that all right I would throw it out
shame no I believe cam I believe you you
guys have all seen me wash my dishes and
put them away on my own record
I'm responsible about you were expecting
the mutually shared space yeah you went
alive I wouldn't lie who was shaving
Yesterday by the way in the bathroom oh
someone left hair in the bathroom
and maybe I left a few hairs but I tried
to call oh call it out okay wow yeah he
was in a rush though
I do admit to that and I'm sorry about
that so wait you were shaving in the
bathroom with what with ab's razor a
flat a razor dude he uses that on his
camera no I I I gave I bought like this
expensive machine to it's a clear my own
hair with the Clipper the beard trim
yeah I'm just always like him mess it up
and shaved my own head by accident so I
gave it to cam to keep me from [ __ ]
myself up you just gave it to him well
he he was using it for a while and I was
like you know I can't Merry Christmas
Kim So cam you oh oh just like a
straight up head buzzer yeah sorry I
misspoke when I said razor but yeah yeah
and so you but you just buzzed your
facial hair off over the sink
I did and I thought I cleaned it up but
I wasn't a rush so I'm sorry how much
hair was left baby
I it wasn't a lie I mean again he was in
a rush yes he was running downstairs
you know I have a thing about hair in
the sink because one time it's one of
the only times my dad
look it's all ancient history but yeah
he he spanked the [ __ ] out of me because
I cut my hair just I was [ __ ] around
and I left all my hair in the sink and
he wasn't mad about anything he was just
like why would you leave hair in the
sink and he like [ __ ] beats such a
specific thing to set somebody off he he
didn't hit me very often but he beat my
ass for that and I never and it really
stuck with me so
I don't like leaving here in the sink
and it looks like uh you got to keep
teach cam a lesson yeah I'm gonna take
you a lesson don't you leave no hair in
the sink now come on over here you want
the belt or the pipe
I usually do do a good job of cleaning
that too but the K-Cups are not me and I
Will Stand My Ground on that
I believe you so cam we're acquitting
Lena we're quitting Dan we're acquitting
who else drinks coffee in this office
okay Santa isn't here but I don't think
she drinks coffee Ian you could answer
that she'd wait what'd you say does Sam
access the Cake Cup machine
uh I don't know I could message her
though
yeah we need to hear we need um she
drinks decaf I think
it's on that's right um
uh I don't think so okay Zach I'm sorry
bro but it's you that's impossible how
is it impossible I would fess up to that
that's [ __ ] up leaving trash out he's
drinking coffee right now who has coffee
right now
I do think you would fess up to it Zach
that's what throws me off I would and I
know someone that did that growing up
and I found it to be disgusting who was
it just someone in my family your
brother who else is there maybe yeah
I will say Zach is very clean he's very
like he wants to get rid of stuff right
away so real real recognize real in this
case could it be a rogue actor uh
we did have the Orchid Man come by is he
drinking coffee the who the Orkin man
the Exterminator
the exterminators leaving trash around
the office two of them
I think everyone who makes coffee has
done that at least once maybe because
it's so easy to do like it's definitely
whoa you just [ __ ] whoa
that all of us who drink
Ing we don't do that because there's
just no oh
it's possible that everyone's done it at
least once a Lena yeah it's like a just
a group effort sort of thing and so what
I'm hearing is that you've done this
before
no no I'm not admitting guilt you said
everybody
you said everybody's done this before
everybody begins with you
I'm saying that for the greater good I'm
willing to admit it's possible I had
done
me people are suggesting Ela No Maybe
yeah yeah I don't think so
he wasn't even up here with him yeah
he's rarely here and when she is yeah
Lena's always bringing drinks over the
tables uh I don't see it yeah like Lena
was doing a mid-show she's making
multiple because no no no Dan yeah both
you and Ila asked for coffee because so
you know you're making multiple so you
take one out you immediately put another
one in running they don't necessarily
run over okay okay you want to come in
my wife who's always leaving their
coffee on the thing on the machine just
their coffee itself
Dan does leave the mug there for 21. on
the machine how can we trust you to
clean up when you can't even get your
car I mean we're talking about we're
talking about a period of like five
minutes like I brew it and and then I go
do something like no that sounds like
there's coffee well hold on one at a
time one at a time this is important we
we need to hear all these perspectives
Dan you leave the mug on the coffee
machine sometimes because oh it takes a
little bit for it to brew so I start it
and then I like run to the bathroom or
something or I go take care of something
it's empty yeah I'm saying like when I
go and Brew The Coffee Cup it warming up
unless it's warming up yes and then I go
do something else tonight and you know
maybe it takes a couple extra minutes to
get back it takes 10 seconds to brew the
[ __ ] thing yeah I'm a busy guy it
takes two seconds to throw it out in the
trash exactly hold on now why does that
bother you baby he's an empty Cup on the
coffee maker and you don't even make
coffee so I'm just defending my wife
here but you noticed it so it is a
problem
he admitted it that because him and cam
do that sometimes which is fine wait
wait wait wait wait wait I do it people
saying it's Dan I literally am the one
who brought this forward because it's
been perfect the perfect [ __ ] why would
I even call attention to it the safest
place to hide is in the Lion's Den
itself nobody was even talking about
this until I brought it up so wow you
knew it was coming
no no what about this what if it was Lou
okay I think what we need to do what
love I feel like it's all of you guys
you're you're all kind of guilty and you
guys are blaming each other but I think
it's all of you I think yeah it's like a
12 Angry Men I think it's your ass
coming here leaving cup
he's not actually in Sweden it's all a
lie he's in it he's Love come out he
never actually alone in the closet we
hit him in the attic to avoid the uh
avoid immigration this whole time right
right right I think what we need to do
is set up a game camera
it's motion activated right right right
and we're gonna get to the [ __ ]
bottom people are gonna this call out
will hopefully have solved the problem
it's not going to Sam you use that thing
I only drink decaf so mine would be
pretty easy to track decaf pods easy oh
[ __ ] I just threw those away I'm gonna
go dig them out of the trash see what
they are let's go I don't remember the
last time I made a cup of coffee though
because I don't really decaf I mean
that's that's a powerful lead
so so Dan is rummaging through the
garden I really don't remember the last
time
it's regular Dan says dan how many pods
were in there
two pods
someone's [ __ ] up here dude
I think what we need to do is genuinely
I want to get a game camera
that's motion activated and at the end
and when we find a cup
we have to go to the game cam look up
the time and we will find you and we
will know who you are okay you cannot
escape and Dan take those pods from the
trash and we're gonna run forensic on
them get fingerprints yeah well my
fingerprints are all over that's not
fair I'm gonna get unduly blamed because
I contaminated the well we'll see if
there's multiple prints on it
okay
the Pod don't fit you must have quit
game camera does Hassan use the machine
no he's all about the uh cold brew [ __ ]
yeah he's innocent
fail camera
what why are they so cheap 70 bucks
that's awesome yeah let's do it motion
activated that's what I want how was it
on yeah while you're at it put one over
the sink too
the dishes are way bigger of an issue
than the K-Cups I kind of agree with
that yeah so let's put it dude this is
awesome get two of them Dan okay because
what was the last thing we couldn't oh
it was the fake
it was the fake nail right yeah yeah
fake nail yeah we never got to the
bottom of that either okay get two game
cams one over the K hole one over the
sink the k-hole
you will be hot
all right that's awesome this can be fun
use this Boom Boom place the order yeah
cams on the way
oh guys a quick call out
if anybody out there is a journalist or
has a website blog vlog
consider
that we have a very noteworthy member of
The Crew Love in Sweden
may or may not benefit
from articles proclaiming his
his uh
fan his uh uh
Renown his renowned right I happen to
just have randomly written up a bunch of
suggested topics here on the screen
to contact me to add more information to
those articles you know it may or may
not eventually put it back up
yeah so may or may not benefit me in
acquiring a Visa yes yes yes
Kebab Pizza connoisseur you're right
right definitely I mean you introduced
us to go Bob Pizza you are essentially
there Emissary to the world yeah we're a
missionary maybe you can get like a
diplomatic Visa instead of like a work
visa if anyone from the US government is
you know that works right go ahead love
well we got meeting Pokemon here okay
that that one that one's a I don't know
she's a huge yeah meeting her
but she does have she does have a
picture of you on her desk yeah that's a
fun little story I think yeah yeah the
creation of Love bot which uh you know
International uh Acclaim right
the crew the life and death of lovebot
and then the resurrection of lovebot
really is there's a long Saga yeah the
robot Jesus
kitchen cooking stream on Twitch you
know those were epic legendary actually
oh thank you thank you thank you yeah
um obviously getting pulled over I
actually have a dickster article already
on that topic so yeah yeah you had a
chandelier in your car which
um is noteworthy I think for sure yeah
chandelier is that it was a viral Tick
Tock too yeah oh true true yeah 500 000.
you got pulled over by the police and
got dragged out of your car using the
jaws of life yep
absolutely
I I thought we could also make an
article on me make getting the Visa
about this what we're doing right now
right yeah what's the kind of like meta
like a meta article this is a moment
we're having a moment right hopefully
it's not like
love trash too
[Laughter]
we don't want articles like that no it's
just genuine articles organic stuff but
this is Rich gambling yeah
which gambling and twitch culture just
in general I'll comment on any topic and
in general and in general anything
literally any article that you can write
on any website I will comment on I will
put my expert opinion as a figure
connoisseur uh as a Swedish person and
yeah love do you how much do you know
about the American Civil War
a whole bunch actually yeah okay so oh
yeah it needs help with one of those
right yeah and the Mariana Trench the I
know someone who's writing an article
about that oh yeah yeah I know a whole
bunch of that I've actually been there a
couple times yeah well do you have any
thoughts on like the political and
economic state of the world
yeah of course I do I I mean I've been
in that field for years I've been in
that field for years well you would be a
perfect conversationalist for uh Jaden
Smith I think I love the story of being
hired is very interesting I to my
knowledge first time in history I've
seen something like that where someone
who lives so far was able to get a job
with such a big show International yeah
International wow that's purely from
being a reply guy too that's powerful
yeah
I'm up yeah and my it's weird my city is
only like 90 000 citizens and I'm I'm on
this crazy large podcast do people in
your town like know you
yeah
he's the psychotic guy that drives
around with a car covered in writing
with a chandelier hanging yeah I've I've
had to done a bunch of embarrassing [ __ ]
with my cards people watching and I'm I
get pulled I'm going to pull over like
30 times the past five months no joke
like literally there's probably just not
a lot going on there do you have a
picture of your car love for people that
aren't aware of of what you've done
I guess so in a sec because when you see
the car you'll understand why he gets
pulled over so yeah your hands off my
[ __ ] car have you gotten in uh any
tickets or anything or they're always
like never never getting tickets yeah if
you were in America you'd be dead bruh
yeah dude I am not doing this you would
have died three times over yes yes yes
oh yeah that you look like a terrorist
straight up right
you should blast the Isis music and see
what happens yeah and I also also have
like the camera on the car when I drive
that's a recent upgrade
so um
[Laughter]
don't write an article about that part
young Swedish man
yeah anyhow anyhow
anyhow all right thank you love thank
you thank you thank you let's move on we
have so much to discuss and my God my
goodness gracious which probably got to
be 30 minutes right damn uh we're at 29
minutes so so good Instinct all right so
let's thank our sponsor real fast and
then we've got a ton of stuff to get to
including Nick ocado is re-sparking the
beef with me which I thought was
buried you know dried aged packaged up
old beef jerky cured salted but
apparently it's not covered in maple
syrup this man is stepping to me once
again as he gets larger and I get
smaller uh we will meet somewhere in the
middle like two photons being fired at
each other uh in the large house wrong
collider you heard they announced the
Breakthrough on uh cold fusion bro yes
we'll see though we'll see
yeah if you guys don't know this um
it's going to be announced I guess
tomorrow or something I think it's today
that uh so Fusion is
basically the dream energy source it's
like the energy hack
it's how stars are powered and they fuse
two atoms together and it releases a ton
of energy
and it's not it's actually not dangerous
at all it's not nuclear it's not
Radioactive It's like and the only
byproduct is like steam right it's just
water it's literally
would be the biggest breakthrough in
technology and human uh advancement
maybe maybe the single biggest one I
don't know it'd be up there yeah it's
it's free energy for the whole world
and so um for the first time they've
been trying to do this for a while they
were able to cause the ignition which is
when you smash the two atoms together
they were able to get more energy out
than they put in
correct which means if that's true then
it is possible for us to have a fusion
reactor
because I think for a long time people
were skeptical because it takes so much
energy it's been a hardly debated thing
yeah yeah if it was really achievable on
Earth or not all things are possible
yeah I mean this has been around since I
want like been talking about remember
when I was in college since the 50s or
something it's been a long time coming
uh but wow this would be dude I'm this
would be such a gift uh
such a godsend of a incredible
breakthrough and it's actually really
interesting how they do it they shoot
like a hundred lasers
uh uh the most powerful laser in the
world apparently 100 what they were
using really 100 of them 192 lasers holy
[ __ ] did they have a video of that
um well all of this was just kind of um
leak well maybe not leaked but just like
a little bit of information coming out
about it today was the day that the big
press conference about it happened and
I'm looking right now I see the New York
Times big article about it from an hour
ago so it looks like the news is finally
out so let's do our ad in the 192 giant
lasers
uh used to do this yeah so it's so what
the hope is is that you you create this
reaction
and then once it reacts it starts a
chain reaction that and it becomes
self-sufficient self
-regulating like a star it's the same uh
method that the engines stars and it's
an incredible amount of energy it's 100
clean and there's no risk for disaster
because once the heat goes away it just
the reaction stops
right there's not a risk of like a
meltdown like in a fission reactor it's
just a loan it's just it's just a loan
from that Universe just alone
you know what I mean this isn't my first
rodeo
Oh [ __ ] all right I'm gonna thank the
sponsor and then actually I want to
learn a little bit more about that uh so
thank you to PayPal honey
two great folks have merged together we
love it
I love my sponsors they're the greatest
today's episode is sponsored by PayPal
honey the easiest way to shop when
saving on your shopping on your iPhone
or computer
guys it's time for that holiday shopping
are you guys getting your shopping done
now or is it already done
I still have stuff to do yeah I haven't
even started okay that's what I was
curious because like
I was uh yeah I think when do you wrap
it up by like the 20th or by like the
24th
like in terms of purchasing stuff
um sometimes I do end up giving a
printed out like this is in the mail I
owe you yeah
um but I will be using honey you better
PayPal honey yeah because everybody
should thank you for the thank you for
putting back on track they're living
you better be using honey because it's
that season to be shopping
and God dang it we better be saving as
much as we can
with that promo code that's ready at
checkout thanks to Honey manual
searching for coupon codes it's a thing
of the past
honey is the free shopping tool that
scours the internet for promo codes and
applies the best one it finds to your
cart imagine you're shopping at one of
your favorite sites you click when you
click checkout the honey button appears
and all you gotta do is Click apply
coupon here's some of our very own dude
Ela is a is that Chick-fil-A
oh
I know but I was shocked by it
yeah this is all just these are all
savings that we've personally here in
this office saved he was a fiend for
this look at that 300 one Hilo got
and I have to emphasize
we did not expect to save this money we
were ready to pay a full price you just
click the button
it automatically searches and then you
apply it it's so freaking easy it's a
no-brainer you don't even have to think
about it dude there's no downside
um it saved us a gajillion dollars
so you can save even more now with honey
they keep track of price drops on your
holiday ship shopping list your prices
drop on anything on your list you
instantly get an alert
that's you know I don't know if you guys
have noticed this on Amazon the prices
these days fluctuate like
by hundreds of percentages like a dog
food will be 25 and then like in a few
days it's fit literally 50 bucks
it's actually insane so those those are
becoming more and more useful those
alerts
yeah if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting the show which we
love oh miss you I use honey on every
browser I love honey get PayPal honey
for free at joinhoney.com h3tv that's
joinhoney.com H3 TV uh please support
our sponsors thank you to honey we love
you thank you thank you yes yes yes yes
ow
someone says when are you revealing your
2022 predictions that will be during the
live show yes December 20th very excited
and should we
uh announce the like the award the
nostrad dumbass award yeah so we decided
it's better to actually give the award
to the person that got the most wrong
rather than the person that got the most
right and uh it will be called the
nostrad dumbass award I still never uh
yeah it's terrible at making predictions
for the year Nostra dumbass maybe
Nostradamus for the winner Nostra
dumbass sure is the winner you know I
have a feeling I won so I tell myself up
dude I definitely want
nobody's touching me I said the queen
dies and covet ends no new major
variants that's me double header LL
there's a lot more than just that and I
believe I said the queen dies this year
too well you didn't say kova's gone I
was the only one who stuck my neck out
for that covet isn't really gone no new
major variant is what we said okay
that's a w a year now you're variant
I don't know
oh
oh
Nostradamus that's right Danny's gonna
lose no yeah but are we trying to make a
play on Dan I have other thoughts unless
he wins he's not uh Omicron Alpha Beta
gamma and Delta yeah I mean there's
still just those those are all old news
why are you what I just looked up the
major variants and oh yeah yeah dude
come on bro okay I'm just saying there's
more than those just two categories does
somebody know is this covid related I
believe there was a prediction about how
many times we were going to get banned
this year and I I think I went high on
that one and the reason that I'm gonna
win from the covet is because like
almost everybody took that bet if you
recall we took bets yes you're right I'm
cleaning up nobody put money on us not
getting banned you know what I mean that
was obvious yeah
I don't know if I expected twice but
whatever so yeah that's going to be fun
speaking of the sound bike Olympics you
know I'm really happy to say that nelk
is basically my besties I'm one of the
boys you are a milk boy now you're full
sender you ripped Arts all day I'm ready
right now you love 21 Savage oh thank
you Karina says I just got off Tick Tock
live you look amazing thank you Queen
thank you oh and then Abigail says Ethan
looking like a snack thank you I wore
the turtleneck for you guys
I've been seeing more posts that are
thirsty for you lately on the sub it's
true oh yeah they're just being a lot of
them it's true people are very
supportive with my weight loss because I
remember when I would
talk about trying to lose weight and
then
people would be like dude Ethan lost so
much weight and I know that I didn't
but it didn't make me sad it's just like
man they're just being nice so I don't
take anyone I don't take any comments
like that seriously yeah I know thank
you sad music a real quick note
um just for people that were unclear on
this somebody asked in the chat is the
live show going to be streamed the
answer is yes big yes that's a big yes
we are planning a total freaking Bonanza
it's been a live show and it's going to
be uh broadcast to our Channel we've got
like a production crew because we sold
more tickets this year so our budget's
hired the first one was only like 300 I
think we lost money on that one but this
one we're actually able to
do a nice budget right so uh yeah so we
got I think I think at the end of the
day we're probably just gonna break even
on it but it's gonna be really fun so
whatever no we're not making money yeah
we can afford
more resources yes
so it's going to be a great episode I'm
super excited and I think the next show
because this one was 700 I think the
next show we should go for 1500 and yeah
we might take the leap up yeah we'll see
how it goes then there'll be some some
profit which I would give to to you guys
we should sell like a 20 000 arena in
that case
but I don't think we make money bro it's
gonna cost like a million dollars put on
that show
so unless you're happy to saddle the
debt all right fine fair enough yeah
somebody asked is it seated yes yes it
will be seated there
I have a jawline again Jesus you guys is
it that bad
thank you guys uh thank you so anyway uh
as I was saying Bella Simmons gotta Lee
not just being nice Ethan you're looking
great okay Bella
[Applause]
looking for a sugar mama here I have
something Bella's a good candidate set
up something new on the show for
breaking news so breaking news Bell's
the goats
[Applause]
we were doing that
uh I did I was uh very quickly doing a
little write-up about it reading through
let me watch this club's article
yeah so um you know these are my guys
let's just watch this is Bradley and uh
Kyle my best friend Kyle with love
please or is it just temporarily like
not feeling we were just talking about
uh liver King oh God I talked about him
on the h3s podcast oh you did yeah I
went to that pot it was good their pods
[ __ ] I watched I watched a bit of it I
thought bro yeah it's good I was avoid
the voice the I told you about the
sounds right yeah
so funny they have a ton of you guys I
know it's like Ripa Dart I ripped a dart
yeah do they think that we're like
serious with that [ __ ] too though
partially no personal okay I think they
know what it is I mean it I mean it's
like well do you know that you're how
serious you are with it I'm gonna go rip
a dart like we could debate we could
debate he says you don't take it
seriously and I says no you should you
are serious bro I'm just spitting facts
you know it's that fat it's that frat
boy uh no but we love Kyle we we kid
Kyle yeah honestly they were cool it was
a good place to have ripped darts but
yeah so yeah if we ever collab with Kyle
we gotta rip a dart together for sure
that's just a cigarette right yeah yeah
oh I'd rip a dart with Kyle what about a
gar
LIC
I'd hit a guard with Kyle
yeah I'd do that
I don't like guards but for Kyle
man I mean did you see the apology thing
I did a bit Yeah but didn't like like
everyone knows knows he's upstairs
see I wish we had a thing to pull up the
uh
do they have like 50 cameras sorry yeah
go ahead no you go ahead sorry I'm just
losing it right now I'm just saying are
you everything good like bro don't skip
past that you gotta where's the
follow-up question tell me more about HP
podcast Studio yo Steiny's mad dude yeah
is that his name 90 years what's his
story I barely I never even seen this
guy practically he's a he's a new
addition to the I guess newer Edition
I've seen his face in some of these
videos I I don't how do you get into
milk now because they're like a big ass
deal you go you know what I mean you're
[ __ ] sick ass full sender dude Steve
will do what I see the dart and you
[ __ ] smoke some Gars like no shoddies
or anything
yeah I love them Kyle's such a Class Act
such a guy he handled himself so well by
the way on their podcast break with that
one loser and I just have tremendous
respect for Kyle as I always have and uh
I think he's a brilliant Creator I
actually have so much I to be honest
respect like crazy all they've
accomplished with the Nook brand yeah
I've always been you know team now hey
Zach you could wear that an elf jacket
that uh I can wear my full sun jacket
now yeah your friend yeah it's all good
it's all kosher baby yeah yeah and uh oh
yeah come in full send full send here
the podcast happy Dad all that [ __ ] yeah
actually I liked happy Dad you guys were
there I drank that [ __ ] and I was a
happy Dad might be the greatest drink
beverage I've ever had in my life you
know is it a beard
better
huh I may have said the opposite on the
show but I'm the cool dad now but now
it's better yeah it's better now in
retrospect
yeah I love them so shout out milk I got
a comment from Adrian who says the main
problem was sustained fusion reaction
micro turbulences in the plasma core the
l-l-n-l achieved a net gain energy
Factor higher than one which is great
but we need a net gain energy factor of
about 10 or higher for Fusion to be
viable replacement for fossil fuels I
think I actually followed most of that
yeah yeah I don't know what reactions
and micro turbulence means but it needs
more
it needs a more efficient it needs to be
more efficient yes
yeah and I've seen estimates that that
could be you know a decades decade two
decades away still but just the fact
that they achieved it at all where like
you said Ethan before there was a lot of
skepticism that it could even be done
you can never get a good exchange of
energy where it would be it took more to
do it than it than you got out of it so
it just wasn't working but if they can
do one right then then [ __ ]
theoretically they can do they can do
more right let's go more more lasers
more just keep and lasers yeah that's
the gotta be the solution lasers are
sick lasers will save us all [ __ ]
lasers
yeah Adrian um thanks for the Insight
but uh just had more lasers so no
problem thank you for the donation thank
you for the donation too is that what
New York Times said just more lasers
uh the article I was reading
uh did not specify more lasers so go to
Scientific America or something they'll
mention the lasers no I mean it
mentioned the lasers I thought you were
asking if it they said more they got
laser lasers no uh it here I have the
relevant part right here uh
they used 192 giant lasers blasted a
small cylinder about the size of a
pencil eraser damn they're just like
[ __ ] little laser there's a lot of heat
boom hitting one little spot
um with that heat
uh size of a pencil racer that contained
a frozen nubbin a nubbin of hydrogen
encased in a diamond damn that sounds
great in a diamond sick yo Legends like
a diamond how cool is that
the laser beam entered the top and the
bottom of the cylinder cylinder
vaporizing it that generated an inward
onslaught of x-rays that compress a BB
size fuel pellet of deuterium deuterium
and try and tritium the heavier forms of
hydrogen so and in a brief moment
lasting less than a trillion 100
trillionths of a second
two megajoules of energy roughly the
equivalent of a pound of TNT bombarded
the hydrogen pellet
wowed a flood of new Trump articles the
product of fusion which carried about
three Mega joules of energy so they put
in two got out three
hey I don't know much but I know that's
a good trip that's a good trade
just so did they mention anything well
how long was the how long was it uh live
for the reaction uh a hundred
trillionths of a second yeah I've I've
experienced shorter uh having experience
shorter
not many yeah I got you but ah all right
I see what you're doing this guy right
here I conduct research in computational
plasma Dynamics at CSULB how the [ __ ]
are you watching this show you're way
too you ever wants to talk Fusion I'm
your guy call in Adrian yeah if uh is he
wait you're the guy who said it's the
same person yeah yeah so so you got did
you understand what I said about more
lasers or do you need an explanation
could you pass that along you can break
that down for you if you need yeah reach
out I would love to talk to you reach
out
foreign that's awesome
so but I can't overstate just what a big
deal this is if we get this going it's
energy for free it's free at real estate
it's free energy
it's free energy from the government
actually it literally is because it was
a government lab maxco would be so happy
right now
Andrew Tates be like I don't [ __ ] with
government energy right
no I thought that was cool too that it
is a uh uh US Government lab that did
this and not like some private research
firm um so good yeah
see our tax dollars are going to
something interesting they they
oftentimes too it's just it gets
overshadowed
well they're like damn damn we can
invent Fusion Energy
but that means there's a hundred Iraqi
Villages that we won't be able to
decimate
we have to do a trade-off
yo Zach what the [ __ ] Howie at this
point is just stalking us like there's
something going on that was a very uh
funny and bizarre interaction we we
chatted with him for like five minutes
um saw him at the mall
and um we were just chatting with like
an old friend and it was he's such a
good guy he was so nice and he was there
with his wife and Chantal was with me so
he met Chantal and um
it was a good time it was a good time
that's pretty cloudy that you can stop
and chat with Howie yeah and I'm like
hey Howie you remember me oh yeah yeah
you're the sound guy and I'm like oh
he's a sweetheart no he was [ __ ] cool
yeah Howie rolls but the the funny thing
about it was after we were talking to
Howie there was a fan of the show that
came up to us after and it was like two
worlds colliding he was saying hi to
both of you well no how he left but he
came up to me and he's like what the
[ __ ] did I just witness
um so yeah it was how he was great he
was super nice yeah but I'm getting a
little concerned because first he was
stalking me
right and Gila right then all of a
sudden he's having lunch with my mom now
he's following you in the mall like this
is way too many encourage with owie
right this is ver this is more than
random chance all right all right
there's got to be a [ __ ] with your mom
was so wild 100 thought he was [ __ ]
around yeah
um
thank you for the Dono Rose
God bless you congrats on that degree
so I don't know what's going on with
Howie if you run into one of us highway
I swear to God again
some we're gonna get to the bottom of
this okay no more
peace and love
nothing
oh you and then more news a b with his
tight [ __ ] little throat you kept
choking on [ __ ] and you you actually
went to get it and uh examined yeah I
got a scope and uh they told me I was
fine so thank you everyone who's
concerned I'm I'm gonna live
oh when was he gonna learn this is the
fusion reactor
does anybody know is this government
related
he's embraced it he wrote a song about
it he did wait wait I was looking for it
this morning I just posted it to work
out this morning can we can we I want to
I want to listen to the I always
prolapse song
he he when I was talking to him it
sounded like he was very much embracing
it like he has the cards displayed
um on his set that's what I that's
always that's all I ever wanted for him
right yeah yeah no he I think he's he's
accepting it all yeah and when when he
God forbid time comes and we're gonna
talk about how he's Legacy
as a great comedian of his time
so you can be prolapse on his tombstone
oh God observe it
I'll make sure of it I'm fine people
oh [ __ ] love him
so yeah so you got so what happened they
actually put you under for that I don't
know what they put me on yeah I I
remember falling asleep and then I
remember being woken up for a second
they were pulling a tube out of my
throat somewhere like the Matrix and I
was like coughing and then I fell back
asleep and woke up in the recovery room
you woke up in the middle yeah I I yeah
it was weird I remember pulling this
tube out did you freak out I remember
going and then waking back up in the
recovery room but oh yeah it was like it
seemed like a few seconds it was weird
oh no yeah did you ask them about it or
are you just like I don't forget I'm
fine yeah I just like let's get the [ __ ]
out of here I was in there for so long
and it was like freezing it was yeah it
was getting bad anxiety in there waiting
for my turn there's like four other
patients in the small room that they
were like wheeling in
damn they just got that like a meat like
a throat [ __ ] machine yeah yeah we're
all yeah
yeah this boom boom boom boom huh so
they looked inside there they didn't see
anything you gotta your throat is fine
throat is fine so what's going on then I
think maybe I'm just eating too fast I
don't know and you learn to chew my food
too big of bites too fast yeah
that's what I said from the beginning
yeah yeah I wish I listened I want to
save 300 bucks hold yourself until
you're on the verge of vomiting yeah I
wish more people listen to me you know
also I guess while we're doing updates
people keep asking about the Marriott
they finally responded uh they told they
gave me a gift card for free stay at the
Marriott and the gentleman uh I guess
was uh fired
they said they shared that with you yeah
yeah a lot of people uh I think it's
just a lot of H3 haters were saying ab's
trying to get old man fired I wasn't but
I assure you I have not lost any sleep
about it because that guy was a nut well
are they sure people who say that are
they showing the context of what have
been like on English lunatic he is I
don't know I don't give a [ __ ] so yeah
if he's doing that with me with three
girls what's he doing with just one girl
alone you know like I don't know
listen God bless there's plenty of I
just listen on on The Daily the New York
Times podcast there's 1.75 jobs for
every worker in America right there you
go no jobs for everybody
okay
[ __ ] him thank you thank you thank you
damn you ruined his life though I'd be
you're comfortable with that that wasn't
my intent but whatever
I'm just kidding it was a skateboard
dude that guy should that guy should be
fired that was ridiculous yeah
Bella Simmons says shout out AB for
wearing Jeff's Barbershop merch
shout out yeah I ran into Jeff over the
weekend
um so are you disappointed or happy that
your throat is fine because like you
gotta
you still gotta work on the problem
right yeah I'm I'm definitely happy I'm
not dying okay yeah I'm not dying
no I was I was scared a little bit a lot
of people were like messaging me uh they
were just concerned and I appreciate it
but I'm glad it's nothing you have
anything to share from that Lena were
you involved in uh
his throat [ __ ]
sorry do I have anything to share about
it was he there you were there yeah I
was they didn't let me stay I could only
drop him off
came back a few hours later but I'm so
glad like he was he was saying when we
left like his throat was fine and I was
so relieved and he was like he was just
like kind of annoyed that he spent so
much money trying to figure out but oh
come on you know now and that's crazy
yeah yeah Lena was like thank God I
could throat [ __ ] you again
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's what I thought too
thank you by the way to uh Manda for
five gifted subbies and Ali Kazam for 10
gifted subbies that's so nice of you
guys
also
friend of the show who had a great
really good appearance on Friday with
Brittany broski
and I'm so happy everyone enjoyed that
episode by the way with Brittany it's
always a hit with her and uh
it's always so much fun with her
she's the greatest
um Gabe sent a cameo
to uh just Express his condolences on a
chronic illness
so you can you can expect
a lot of sensitivity here from Gabe he
famously uh consoled someone whose
parent died I'm sorry about your dad
passing away
which is an all-time favorite
but this one's pretty good yeah
wait hold on yeah
I know what you did Mary Beth you stupid
chronic illness you have a stupid
chronic illness because you're a [ __ ]
cause you're a big old lesbian that's
why you do stupid [ __ ] that's why you
have that stupid chronic illness very
best that's why you're a [ __ ] you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ]
I love how he says big old lesbian yes
can you we gotta get that big old
lesbian It's gotta yeah it's gotta be
that they said yeah
and he followed the script perfectly I
think he did a beautiful job he's so
[ __ ] good and I feel like he's
offering a service
that nobody else can on Cameo it is yeah
incredible
no do you uh I never hear you guys talk
about Cameo anymore do you do cameos
anymore
I guess it's just falling into a rhythm
now
yes they'll do it you guys making some
good money well the Well's running dry
no I personally I still get like a few a
week you get a few a week what's your
price at now
I think it's at 75 Maybe
let me try it you raised it to send what
was it before
55. that's a good price 75 what do you
what'd you all this Cameo rate
I quit you quit you quit yeah I didn't
want to double dip since I was doing
this on Twitch
oh that's a good point I guess so yeah
no I'm double dipping like a
[ __ ] then because I'm on Twitch
too
yeah well
we know what I know
I'm not gonna say it I'm not gonna like
say it
we love baby
well how much is y'all's uh how much is
your rate come on cough it up
uh Zach's not here mine's still 55. I do
a few oh dude 55. it's a bargain because
if you consider the Apple tax yeah it's
35 after oh I think I think Zach's 55 as
well
on cameo
you still charge 55 on cameo
what a bargain so how many cameos you do
in a week Zach
um it's kind of dipped down since I I
started on I'm not speaking for everyone
else here that's on it but um I don't
know two three a week that's it yes that
seems like what AV is getting yeah
um but yeah
well Christmas is coming up guys if you
want uh one of these guys to wish one of
your relatives a safe passing into the
Afterlife I'll write a song about it a
condolences about the chronic illness
I'm sorry that you have an unincurable
terminal illness if you have any enemies
you want uh cursed or uh cursed out
rather or cursed I guess you could yeah
death threats bomb threats
and big old lesbians you want to say
anything to
Chloe
God bless you
uh
Graham Jam
my partner was gonna get a B Cameo for
Christmas but it was too expensive and
then
and then they went to Zach's Cameo
instead let's go that's awesome dude
yeah
if they like both of us I say goes back
it's cheaper you'll get a song or
whatever you'll get more out of it so
once for me I have to specifically be
fans of me and that's it I've seen ab's
tick tocks they're not are cameos
they're not great or go to Ian too he
gives he does a really good job as well
they can be great
they can be it depends what they ask if
they ask for like advice or something
I'm sincere but if it's just like happy
birthday what if they go open your
throat as wide let me see down that
that's business price baby yeah it's
that tight little [ __ ] manhole
sorry sorry
I shouldn't say that
a juice dispensary a man juice
dispensary
now I'm getting into fanfiction because
I'm trying to think of ways to describe
your [ __ ] alone throat this is just
so funny juxtaposed to earlier when we
were taking photos and you were like too
too much touching too much touching we
were doing Christmas photos
and um everybody
we we had an idea to do a big pile on
and I just I didn't want to be touching
people uh but the girls ended up doing
which i i Sport
but if you none of y'all could support
my way because you were against I was my
ribs I felt like cracked underneath me I
weigh more than probably Ela and Lena
combined so you didn't you don't want
any of that
yes sorry keep going you were telling
Ivy he has a [ __ ] throat yeah I was
just trying to think of more fan fiction
ways to describe baby's throat
um
they love the word member in fanfics
remember to describe a penis that's
their favorite one
a member hole
a a member vacuum
now let's do this let's not do this do
you have any descriptions for it if
you're brother and sister want to make
love
my throat yeah okay all right I see
I don't know
moving on
a ninja actually we want to thank ninja
because he user two three nine six you
know I came out pretty hard against him
last week I said and I'm gonna apologize
right now for that I said that he is
basically like a
prison guard at a concentration camp
doing you know 720 no scopey no looky
fakie Audis on prisoners trying to
escape and stuff
and so I take that back you know he said
something about Jews having big noses
which I thought was a little
inappropriate
[Music]
and then before that
uh I apologize for what was it did I
apologize for last time
uh for saying that did you say
um about him looking like a an old
lesbian yeah yeah well I didn't I should
apologize for that that wasn't what I
was
that was weird yes you should I should
apologize for that yeah yeah big lesbian
you're a big old lesbian no he's a
skinniest
oh yeah the Balenciaga thing see that
it was an old vid
before the Scandal it's not fair yeah
well there's a new Ninja clip just
dropped
let's take a look
688 messages on Tick Tock how do you
feel about Jewish people
the same I feel about
all humans
the same
they're all right we're all we're all
alright
hey man if Daddy some clickbait
is that Kanye you know what we need to
do a highlight Ninja on the Jewish
question
oh my God
yeah so he answered the Jewish question
he says we're all right he said we're
all right
so I thought you know hey you know what
Ninja
yeah All Is Forgiven he's all right
[Music]
I do still think he needs to visit the
Holocaust Museum and get a tour from a
Survivor or something just to put him in
place I'm not you know
but I did see him oh did he say they're
alt right let's see okay interesting
[Music]
whoa oh no okay also interesting angle
ninja just said all lives matter
I heard all right that's the Highlight
title ninja is the proponent of the all
lives matter movement dude that's so
[ __ ] up wait play that sound bite
again we're all right yeah I heard all
all right we're all right
we're all right I thought we're going
positive direction why don't we just do
ninja ends racism
no that was David Guetta oh yeah he
already had a hold of that title right
shout out to his family a great a great
savior a winner by the way I think of
the first year that uh the first uh
Samba tournament yeah so we actually
have I think we need a Hall of Fame
where we have all the winners so
obviously we've got the shout out to his
family that fine because we need
you know when you go to like Lakers uh
where the Lakers play they have up the
jerseys all the retired great players
yeah so I think we need to do that as
well
thank you
[Music]
[Laughter]
he takes up five percent it's back I
don't [ __ ] care it's back not gonna
say anything about it no building it's
just fun just listening just funny on
its own stands stands alone there's been
so many times where
yeah I I give you my blessings okay I'm
gonna roll with it because it's a it's a
World Champ no you know it [ __ ] no it
has some element of diplomatic immunity
I feel but that's what I think
diplomatic immunity it has a new meaning
at this point it's been so it's got
nothing to do with her nobody even knows
who she is yeah
oh yeah we don't know who she is we
don't I don't even know who she is it
takes that five percent she's literally
some random Tick Tock girl Alexandra
says all we're all white oh [ __ ] did he
say we're all white
see that's not cool
[Music]
anyway here's Joe Rogan exercising guys
did you mean to skip 9A
9A you supposed to yeah
you asked for that one oh yeah and I
want to deprive the audience of this
gold
okay well we just got on a
on a ninja uh kick this might turn
things around oh nine a but he still
didn't apologize to to Pokemon yeah well
okay I'm not done with it listen listen
the Jews forgive him right but will the
world I can speak for all Jews I am the
representative
people always treat me like the uh
representative for all Jews everywhere
but then the next day he had thank you
for reminding me I did want to watch
this he had a bit he had a heated gamer
moment against a child
laughs
yeah let's listen
[Music]
a fun time
drunk
and he's Pawn potting on me shooting me
in the back well I you know what I mean
like Hey listen dude
isn't the Lions beat the Vikings today
all right I gotta smoke and a hot wife
you know what I'm saying
right I got I got multi-millions in the
bank account right I got more money than
your entire [ __ ] family tree has had
in the last probably a thousand years
combined you know what I'm saying right
and you're stream sniping a drunk ninja
31 year old grown man on a Sunday night
drunk off the most says and you're pom
ponding on me I want you to think about
what's happening right now I'm gonna go
to bed and I'm gonna be happy and you're
gonna go to bed and you're still gonna
be a [ __ ] loser
yo that is such a [ __ ] great it's
like he's literally talking to himself
it's like you have all these things
and you're still online bitching to a
child you go I'm a 31 year old grown man
it's like and yet here you are it's like
that movie that reminded me from that
scene that movie Glenn Gary Glenn Ross
you ever seen it without Baldwin yeah
yeah yeah yeah he's like you see that
outside I made a million dollars this
year
it's just reminded me of it I don't know
yeah vibes
that's always reselling right ABC oh
yeah yeah always be closing always be
closing
smoking a hot wife
and like this guy already has a history
he's the braless wife guy my sandwich
pull up the tweet my my wife just my
braless wife just brought me a sandwich
he says
Reddit
31 year old grown man on a Sunday night
drunk off the Moses
I am in the middle of carrying a League
of Legends game about to close it out
and my braless wife brings me a sandwich
not asked for what chips as they get a
double kill bot Lane so how's your day
going to that is an all-timer man it is
I got a smoking a hot wife you know what
I'm saying and then why you gotta Flex
on a child about your wealth it's like
it's like he's he's a child dude cool
you made a bunch of money but
it's just weird
um
also
I don't know
I'm sure so I don't know if this offsets
the
oh and what I was going to say is he's
giving this guy the best W ever as a
stream sniper this is amazing oh yeah
you could open dream for make a whole
video out of the Tilt his ass like that
so drunk
also drunk on mimosas
uh don't at your own house like I can
forgive mimosas at brunch
he may have gone to brunch before that
we don't know I'm drunk oh no he said he
was watching the Lions game who like are
you watching football and drinking
mimosas yeah is that questionable
Behavior
I don't know I'm gonna hate on mimosas
I'm not gonna hate all mimosas I'm not
gonna do that I'm not gonna go there I
actually don't like mimosas I think it's
overrated on a regular day you're gonna
pop a bottle of champagne and also open
an orange juice yeah because he goes
that's a lot we're celebrating honey
you're hot and I'm rich yeah and you
can't save champagne so he definitely
popped popped a bottle oh this is good
this is for when he does this he's
called crinja
thank you
oh
dude I'm sorry but you just keep giving
you know you keep serving up the doves
like are you having a fun is this guy
having a fun time
I'm drunk no game audio is killing me
and he's Pond potting on me
shooting me in the back well I you know
what I mean like hey you know what I
mean there's an alliance beat the
Vikings today all right I got a smoke
and a hot wife you know I find that such
a weird Flex I've got a smoking hot wife
dude I think he might be a contender for
some of somebody there just in my
opinion oh for real what do you got just
the I can't control my goo oh that's a
solid I think out of all of them there's
like I don't know foreign
that you play all the time right
yeah
right right are the Balenciaga ones good
too
that's a new addition I mean yeah that's
a lake you can see him doing this when
you play it play it everybody will see
this in their minds
well also we have the the [ __ ] thank
you for the gift dude which has become a
great thing but also hello
I'm ninjas
guys I'm so excited for Friday this is
like probably my favorite this is our
Super Bowl it is it is it's my favorite
episode of the Year mimosas for the
soundbite tournament I'm open to that
there we go
hot wife bring me a mimosa yeah you know
42 year old man drunk on mimosas can't
you just say like I have a I'm in a
loving relationship my wife's hot I
gotta smoke and a hot wife my wife's hot
[ __ ] loser
all right ninja uh hates uh let me
Love's really being we didn't love Jews
that'd be a different problem he says
Jews are all right
passive on Jews
I still think he said all right like
everybody so you know what I mean he's
he's he's not really positive or
negative on anyone passive yeah and if
there was a pro and if something ever
came out like a problem for Jewish
people around the world he'd remained
passive probably yeah
yeah
he's just apathetic about Jewish people
it's the bystander
just following orders
Ninja
oh [ __ ] here's Joe Rogan exercising
you're gonna love this [ __ ] the title of
this post by the way on his own
subreddit Joe Rogan Kettlebell workout
has more comedic value than his stand-up
here it is guys this is how you begin
Alpha
even the guy who's like who's trying not
to laugh look at his ass
there it is
when you are too loud at the library
true huh
I could see that as like an old uh H3
video totally yeah
someone said his you know it's intense
when your face morphs into stylvester
Stallone
hey uh I'm lifting over here
[Music]
yeah I'm surprised he's able to lift
like that without his nipples getting in
the way
ah that gets my dick hard
so there's Joe Rogan the alpha King oh
yeah so so here's what I want that grab
that as a shushing sound so we're gonna
need someone to be quiet we play Joe
Rogan
thank you
congrats Hunter and Patty
on the marriage absolute Legends we love
love over here and Oddball pogbrook 34
hours round trip to be there with where
the [ __ ] shout out to you uh that's like
almost cross country I know
it's a long drive maybe not maybe not
that's all that's round trip so
guys
Andrew Tate is back man and he's
collabing with
uh
who can only be described as the most
important stream of Our Generation
Aiden Ross cultural total Force [ __ ] you
they actually shot a porno together
which is cool I appreciate how no I did
they are for how homophobic they've both
been in the past I think it is a Big W
for them to finally Embrace who they
really are and he's got a Versace table
which versus uh the Versace obviously
very gay
so he's not going to what would be a
good title for it Bulls bull uh
humiliates twink
Hassan posted a good one it was like
power bottom yeah let me grab it I would
say top G little G or maybe something
like that
g little dude love that
yeah people asking for real yes it's it
was posted on PornHub uh last week
you can uh seek that out yourself if you
like the picture is real if that's what
you're asking I think Aiden flew out to
Romania or somewhere so that he could
suck him off in person International
International
uh
banging something like that
International bang Fest yeah oh Aiden
Ross's tight little [ __ ] throat
[ __ ] Aiden Ross gets creampied
he's Aiden Ross white chess pieces
top oh that's better than top G little G
what you got G bottom G people are
saying top G bottom key Aiden Ross asked
G ascasm
is good
top ask them but I feel like these are
too flattering to to
um
to tape
Bull's first gay experience
Aiden Ross gets checkmated
somebody suggested it's good it's very
good oh my God this is from the same um
yeah I just I opened the stream to find
out where it took place and that's the
first this one's actually Aiden Aiden
took his shirt off at one point too
there's there's screenshots this one
this one hit so hard it's just the
posture it looks like he's Still Loving
no pants on like he just [ __ ] him or
something today I feel uh gay yeah
appreciate it
um
yeah it's a powerful we should have a we
should have a pride minute I think for
Andrew and and
okay one second Aiden oh I got I got one
more stop watch going one more screen
grab I think yeah let's pull that up for
Pride minute yeah this one is important
pride pride
yeah so we didn't start it yet no hold
on hold on oh my God this is a casting
call
dude no way look at this [ __ ]
strip for me baby young twink gets used
and abused
by casting agent right
yeah so I just want to say we're gonna
start priming it uh start the timer for
a second just uh because I don't want to
go over timer set up my fear with pride
minute is going over I got one more yeah
yeah yeah you definitely don't want to
do that you definitely here I'm gonna
have eight
in just a second here okay dude [ __ ]
twinks so hard he gets banned off the
internet
pump that one whoa who got banned though
okay wait did you post another one no no
oh I thought you were saying that's a
big game man that's a bit gay man all
right there we go I have it on screen
all right and all right then it begins
right now so I want to congratulate
Aiden and Andrew for coming out together
I know they are close okay
and I think that men in general have
repressed their sexuality
to the point where it manifests in this
kind of toxic masculinity that you see
in Mr Tate here
bisexuality is so much more open and
accepted amongst women
but I think bisexual men are looked at
as gross and weird by people
and so I want to say that how proud and
I am of Andrew coming out as a kind of a
bisexual king try
because we need to demystify this so
that homies can kiss each other and
touch each other
like they always wanted to without being
you know thought of being a gross and
that's it's just not fair it's not right
and I think Andrew's bringing that to a
much needed hypermatastic toxic
masculinity sexuality is a spectrum and
that's a minute stop close it stop [ __ ]
up these idiot freaks freaks you need
Jesus I'm not gay no more dude y'all
need Jesus
Andrew back in the closet Aiden you're
coming home
shame on you both
shame
this makes me sick I know it's just a
screen cap
and they didn't actually make love I
pray that
what US makes me sick
I bet you Andrew's dick is just one
millimeter away from being seen that
they gonna produce mentally [ __ ]
Offspring right well they can't breathe
far as I'm aware it there isn't any
shame on y'all
you make the choice to touch a penis and
you make the choice to commit so to me
public nudity calls are interesting you
must walk away and Repent Jesus what's
your argument Andrew Tate he's a he's a
Muslim I mean shame on you bro right
yeah not cool dude I dare you to show
this to her
what do they call the Aiden is uh Jewish
actually
um
oh maybe we should have played on that
like the Jewish Muslim gangbang oh he's
in the Middle East [ __ ] oh
yeah yeah get getting a piece in the
Middle East no but peace peace in the
Middle East would be like like a piece
of something oh how about this how about
this Islamic Bowl [ __ ] the Jew out of
little twink
is it kosher or hello no like a rabbi
like a like a yeah what's the name of a
shack
[Laughter]
a little bit of dick
yeah I just want to say I dare you
Andrew to show this to your Shack
chic
and say either Shack I dare you to show
this to Shaq I dare you to share this to
Shaquille O'Neal be very confused he'll
say why why delete me from this
conversation
yeah but this is disgusting shame on you
guys repress those feelings get back in
the gym hang out with your homies show
each other's muscles smell each other be
and the sauna naked together but do not
have sinful thoughts
trust me we don't you think all men wish
that we could just suck dick and have a
good ass gay [ __ ] time we all
want that but you have to resist for
Jesus Christ is touching the pain is
really worth a lifetime of damn Nation
eternally amen [ __ ] yes oh he he
disagrees same is just another type of
meal I'm the one getting plowed
now if you want to drink his semen ain't
Aiden y'all need him to come into a cup
and then leave the room so it's not gay
you understand that's the game then you
can drink his semen it's not gay
but if you watch him it is gay love that
God that filter looks fantastic I want
to see it thank you it's just Jesus oh
this is interesting what about what
about a kosher bottom gets his top
G-spot stimulated yeah that's great
it's a little bit of a stretch but we're
working on it stretch like stretch like
stretched like Aiden's [ __ ]
intestines
wow all right let's let's move on before
we
go
we're telling the line for for a minute
here
repent
amen
I'm a man of God
I'm a man of G or no I'm a man of
Muhammed I don't know what's the X in
life
[Music]
um
can I say Muhammad can I say his name
yeah yeah just don't show a picture
visual depictions that's you know so can
I ask you
and I'm and I don't mean disrespect I'm
genuinely pursuit of of curiosity
do they not know do Muslims not know
what Muhammad looked like we're not
supposed yeah we're not supposed to
depict them it's the same way that like
you know Jesus got whitewashed and like
you know today's world it's it's we're
not supposed to idolize men that's
that's why we don't depict him okay
that's that's cool that's that's
actually Good Vibes I think yeah so he
doesn't get like turned into a white
dude with blue eyes exactly yeah this
causes divisiveness it's like you
shouldn't you know depict him right but
that's interesting they do it to prevent
this divisiveness
here's Shaq actually so he is interested
but they get real or not I shouldn't say
they but extremists get really angry
when you show a picture like is that
what it seems like maybe I have a
misunderstanding but that seems like a
really bad thing to do yeah I mean I
don't know extremists get mad about
anything so right okay well South Park
got into some some Mega heat for that
yeah yeah I remember they had a whole
episode
they can't even show those I think it
was I think it was the pl yeah but it
was like the plot of a
yeah I was I was of an episode where
Family Guy was going to show Muhammad
and they were trying to stop it right
yeah yeah yeah yeah South Park yeah and
by the way two episodes you correct me
if I'm wrong maybe but um it's not
actually just Muhammad it's any of like
the prophets yeah it's any of the
prophets so like even like Moses or
Abraham or like anybody from the Bible
but they don't care about Moses they do
of course they do they do we care Jesus
no I mean I mean like they don't they
are the extremists don't get buckwalled
about pictures of most well Muhammad
obviously is the most important one but
uh but that that whole no visual
depiction thing it's it's not
specifically Muhammad
Moses yeah of course Jesus yeah who else
we [ __ ] with [ __ ] with in Islam Jesus
yeah you got to think Jesus
think of Christianity as the expansion
pack to Judaism and then the DLC is uh
Islam they're all they're all built on
one another yeah we we believe
everything that came prior it's just
like it's kind of funny how each major
religion is like nah this is [ __ ]
and then the the Muslims like are the
Christians like not every this [ __ ]
and then the the
Muslims are like nah this is all good
yeah it's pretty funny it's also the
cause of a huge amount of conflict over
centuries so in that way it's not that
it's a long-running joke
it's an old-timey joke yeah
we need something new we need to it's
about time for a DLC to to uh I think
that's uh that's Mormonism that's that's
the latest drop but they did they
believe in Muhammad and all that uh
actually no right because Mormon is
Divergence from uh yeah it's a retcon
it's a retcon yeah it's like uh what do
you call it it's like a re when they
remake it's a remake yeah yeah it's a
it's a soft reboot it's a soft reboot I
still can't believe that you guys don't
believe in hell like that was so
surprising to me it's like the core of
everything we do it's being Muslim is
playing life on hard mode well there is
a Jewish hell but it's our difficulty
but it's like what's it called uh is it
shul or something like that sure is
sure can be hell right
yeah there's a little bit of nuance to
that but yeah it's not like internal
damnation yeah it's different yeah
Heaven and Hell and Judas tradition here
you want to learn about it right now
yeah I
find it interesting okay I think they
should teach more about it in school
because I think people will be more
tolerant like Dan knows more about Islam
sometimes than I do on all religions and
he told me he was taught that growing up
which is awesome yeah the church that I
went to was very uh liberal artsy if you
will and um our our sort of Sunday
school we just it was sort of just like
a
General religious theology class more
than any specific Doctrine so that is
why I know I don't want to say a lot but
I know some thing about Islam
here it says
the subject of death is treated
inconsistently between the Bible
or in the Bible it's inconsistent it
often suggests that physical death is
the end of life this is the case with
Abraham Moses and Miriam however
several biblical references to a place
called Shoal
is described
as a region dark and deep the pit and
the land of forgetfulness where human
beings descend after death this
suggestion is that in the northern world
of Shoal the deceased although cut off
from God and humankind live on in some
shadowy state of existence that sounds
like a dope [ __ ] place for like
Kratos to smash through I was going to
say it sounds like a dark souls level
the video game
while this version of Shoal is rather
bleak
setting precedence for later Jewish and
Christian ideas for underground hell
there's generally no concept of judgment
or reward and Punishment attached to it
Jews yeah it's somewhat similar to the
uh Christian uh idea of purgatory it's
more of just kind of like a
Eternal waiting room dude that's awesome
sign me the sort of some sort of
punishment I'm there no it says there's
no punt judgment or punishment
associated with it yeah not us we Shacks
find new ways to be creative and tell us
how we're gonna [ __ ] suffer and as
and the Hellfire is not normal Hellfire
it's like [ __ ] that's so it got the
hell got more intense it seems as the
iterations continued oh yeah Jews are
like no hell Christians are like somehow
but easy easy win
no no our hell is like Muslim
progression hell is is pretty bad it's
the person
they say if you accept Christ you get
yeah I mean I think it's a fairly easy
job in Islam as well really dude a shack
told my cousin once that they're gonna
lock your soul in a [ __ ] box
flame arrows from the hottest [ __ ]
Flames like 100 times hotter than
[ __ ] heat whatever lava and they're
just gonna shoot it at your soul
repeatedly in this box and then they're
gonna bring they're gonna your Skin's
gonna regenerate and they're gonna do it
again that's pretty that sounds like
child of metal as [ __ ] yeah oh yeah
kind of mythical though
uh they say in fact the more pessimistic
books of the Bible such as
ecclesiatus and job and I don't know I'm
not familiar insists that all the dead
go down to show whether good or evil
rich poor slave or free man so it's kind
of like a egalitarian uh just word the
souls just go it's like the soul resting
place
we just all go down there you know what
I mean yeah yeah so it's not like
demonic necessarily no not demonic and
it's not a judgment either you know
yeah let me just say um it's not all
Muslims obviously that's like all
religions some people believe to an
extreme and others are more yeah
absolutely there's a whole spectrum of
it
yeah I'm curious to learn more about uh
what is Helen Judaism according to
Jewish teachers hell is not entirely
physical rather it can be comprised to a
very intense feeling of Shame
people are ashamed of their misdeeds and
this constitutes suffering which makes
up
the bad deed that tracks so much
with at least the Jewish culture that I
grew up around that the ultimate version
of hell is like just feeling really
guilty
that's our life as a Muslim we should
feel guilty our whole life yeah it's
just your Jewish mother guilting you so
yeah that's how so much wasted potential
that's Hillary in other words hell hell
is right here on Earth
many Jews believe that after a person
dies his or her boss Soul simply doesn't
vanish a part of the Soul remains with
the body
stuck in limbo until burial is the job
of the shomer or shomaret to comfort the
deceased Soul okay we need a little
coaxing
what is the most unforgivable sin in
Judaism blasphemy against the Holy
Spirit what
damn
one Eternal or unforgivable sin
blasphemy against the holy spirit is
also known as the sin unto death is
specified in several passages of the
blah blah blah blah what are we going to
do what they don't care we don't care
about Holy Spirit do we
it's sort of the same in Islam it's like
believing in multiple gods is like the
worst thing you could do
but it's not what Christianity is all
about they're like well I guess it's the
same God
yeah yeah done that's good let's not go
down that path all right we love we love
all religions they're great people you
know some take it too far but hey don't
we all have moments we take things too
far yeah
it's just a prank bro it really at the
end of the day it's all just a prank
um you're a weirdo bro
tweeted about their meeting this morning
let's see
reading books is okay
yeah so this I don't think is serious we
kind of talked about this bait it's just
bait stupid
I'm not even gonna read it yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] you Andrew Tate [ __ ] ass I'm just
saying uh for he's so against reading
books it's kind of hard to follow Islam
when it's based around a book okay let
me read it let me read it it's a good
point
he reading books is for losers who are
afraid to learn from life this is a take
synonymous with cooking is for idiots
and betas or whatever so they try and
learn from the life others have lived
but you never really learn unless you've
lived it you must feel it to believe it
books are a total waste of time
education is for cowards
stupid you know what he doesn't believe
that he's fallen off like he's trying to
play the hits he's trying to play oh I
don't drink but don't drink government
water it's all about bubbly water like
the Absurd [ __ ] he used to say and he's
trying to like go back to that energy
but like this just
it just doesn't have the same punch as
government water I'm sorry he's turning
into Bob Dylan yeah he's like new Bob
Dylan yeah actually I agree with the
with the center that's something I've
always agreed is that you can't really
learn something unless you've lived it
like internally to really feel and
understand what it means uh but he
really packs it up in a nice little
thing here readings for losers and
educations for cowards
yeah so he only believes in videos I
think he he has like Muslim for idiots
video series yeah
did Philly D really just donate from his
clip's channel come on Philly
I'm not even number one don't come here
until I'm number one I'm off by like
four thumbnails you can't hit that by
the end of the year
come on Phil oh Phil will you go on a
hike with my lookalike
you can't no you're you're gonna go on a
hike with them he's not giving away the
game he's not he's not gonna be down if
I I gotta Prime him for it
no I'll be I'll be there right
yeah
Billy's gonna send a look-alike to do
the steamies with you I'm so down for
him to send a look-alike that'd be so
funny
two randos my best friend pull up of
your local yeah they're just besties
hiking together
yeah okay Andrew Tate whatever but yeah
Phil said he needed tone for your sins
and join Phil Anthology philanthology
bro you're not
you got to donate more than that if you
want a promo
what is philanthology is that a real
thing or the joke
it's it's no I practice it it's unreal
Oh I thought you said it was the name of
his Eclipse shell or something
I'll join philatology let's talk talk to
me about it on a hike
I'll have my extra take notes hell and
that religion is just an endless hike
hell is just him going
away
it's just the boulder over and over
again
yo Ivan said I wore my issue podcast
shirt on the first day and got laid
shout out to the family
women are I'm telling you women are out
there they're just looking for men that
like this show also the girls who watch
this show are so hot it's so true
they're the most beautiful people in the
world smart obviously have a great sense
of humor watching History Podcast gives
you perfect skin
it's a high IQ podcast yeah yeah
you know anyway thank you for the
donation Phil
um
please go on a hike with my extra
it'll be super funny with with you
I can do it so it's a little effort for
you like he'll show up at your somewhere
near your house and then you can bail
you don't have to do the whole thing and
then he just goes on a hike by himself
see that's funny you know what I mean
okay
thank you
I gotta pee guys
but we still have the best parts we have
the game awards troll
we have the uh Nick ocado calls me out
maybe we should do that next yeah and
Elon gets good let's do that let's do
Nick ocado and then Elon gets booed
okie doke but I'm just gonna go to the
bathroom I'll be right back thank you
thank you peace and love peace and love
peace and love
I'm not taking a pause to pee well here
we are again back at it again a Krispy
Kreme
ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the crew waits for Ethan to
take a [ __ ] show
okay he says it's not a [ __ ] it's just
gonna be a p this time well it's kind of
like a double entender
you know [ __ ] show taking a [ __ ] show oh
true and this show usually is a [ __ ]
show
look Olivia can't be saying uh all his
girls are hot definitely not hot do you
understand this
is he just calling me ugly no no no no
no no no no I was just wondering if I
was uh
to not Zoomer enough to understand I
can't yeah
Hello Olivia
no she's just saying sure I think she
isn't home she isn't hot uh not true
that's not true your beauty that's not
true
by the way
that was My K-cup you [ __ ] idiots no
wait what no I'm kidding whoa why would
you even [ __ ] joke about that it's so
inappropriate bro I'm just playing out
the audience saying it was me people in
chat were saying that I was being really
quiet but I don't drink hot coffee so
yeah me neither
that's also is that
I've never seen Olivia I have only used
it if Ela or Ethan asks and Lena's
downstairs oh so you might have provided
it for somebody but you're not familiar
with the K-Cup dispenser
no no I don't know how long those Cups
have been there no absolutely not oh
this is actually interesting everybody's
a suspect the little cups over to the
garbage if I ever do it and I can't even
remember the last time I did um
do you know what Olivia did earlier
we're downstairs doing this photo shoot
and the girls like we were saying
they're all like stacked up on each
other Olivia and Sam and Lena and Ila
and they had to scoot over a little bit
for the shot and Olivia lifted them up I
was so impressed so hurtful on my ribs
yeah
but I did
um I did feel very appreciated after I
did it so it's happening and you also
still have your injured wrist from the
dog bite too yes yes very true but it's
healing well yeah but still you were
able to see
lift everybody it's so crazy though I
mean it's still very invisible it's
still gross also his teeth like
scratches are still there too Donnie
Donnie Danny Ainsley said uh my lovely
boyfriend introduced me to H3 and now
I'm obsessed with it and I love it shout
out Jesse love you shout out Jesse we
love you too Jason he's a friend
spreading the good word that actually
reminds me I
I don't usually do this but I have
somebody to shout out
somebody who introduced today is
Wednesday
a friend of mine
hello
hello thank you for the gift here it is
Hunter
Hunter if your name is Hunter and you're
friends with Justin
thanks for watching buddy I appreciate
you what the hell is that a real life
friend of mine told me he found out one
of his friends is obsessed with the show
and asked if I could shout him out
sometime Hunter Hunter where does he
live let's get some info I think he is
in the uh Massachusetts uh hell yeah
region shout outs Hunter dude you know
what he looks like I know nothing about
him other than that he's friends with my
friend Justin my voice and that he likes
the show and he's from Massachusetts
he's a stud what does she do for a
living you don't know anything about him
you didn't get more you want to say let
me get his address real quick well it's
a social I would just like to know as
much as possible about Justin our big
fan Justin oh my God wait is it hunter
or is it Justin Rochelle no uh we're
shouting out a hunter Justin's Justin's
my friend I know him from I went to
college with him is his last name Biden
it's
oh oh
does he have is there pictures of his
dick on the internet
whoa
that was powerful
I'd be I'd be cool if Hunter Biden was
watching
so shout out uh to you know
let's talk about Nick O'Connor because
that's why we're all here let's not
[ __ ] mince words stop [ __ ] around
now there's a lot of history between me
and Nick
go ahead with the okay I'm just giving a
flavor okay I like The Vibes it's not a
war but I like that okay
he was meant to come out and do our
podcast we've we had bought him a ticket
we put him up in a nice hotel he said
five star only right and we said we
can't oh in first class but didn't we
accommodated he did want first class uh
I don't think he didn't request a
five-star hotel
um we put him in a nice one just because
we were
that's we usually
he requested from us a first class
ticket first class and we said you know
what you were a star and and we will pay
that and it was specifically because of
his weight he sitting in coach is very
uncomfortable for him so it felt like a
fairly reasonable request given that
contest
okay there you go he's a two-seater
he wasn't a two-seater but but the The
Wider seat up in first class was uh
appreciated uh Jay fella thank you for
the gifted Jay fella that was uh one of
the yes one of one of the right uh diss
tracks that oh yeah it got very far
wasn't Jay fellow the the father who was
just making not the one everyone wanted
to win I think so right Jay fella had a
very strong support base in his back he
didn't take the whole thing but
uh his uh was quite good maybe we should
have another freestyle um
that was really fun I feel like we need
a really strong enemy like like capcav
is just so ripe for Destruction like
that well when trailer dies which is
going to we should do a rest in peace
trailer that's not a bad idea or I mean
[ __ ] yeah let's do it next year next
year next year get ready
yeah so and then it all kind of fell
apart because
I was doing a bunch of videos about him
on the Ethan Klein Channel
and I thought we were joking around I
thought we were lightfully ribbing each
other because let's face it
he doesn't take himself seriously at all
he walks around in a tiny shirt with his
stomach out he's playing this
over-the-top character he doesn't take
himself seriously
I did take it too far I said like for
example because you know he's on only
fans and you can see like really graphic
shots of him that kind of just surprised
me and I did maybe say at one point that
his [ __ ] looked like a cow's vagina I
guess that part maybe was too far rod
and car Polk I believe that was the
straw I remember yes being at school and
getting ready to come back to be here
for the interview and I was watching
that video and I was just like
he's not coming he's definitely not
coming and I I just I accepted it I I
personally didn't really see that as an
insult it's really a compliment because
that's the goal and his kind of content
is to be have gaping to be gaping right
I think like that was his intention Dan
yeah what it's not like to look like I'm
not even gonna say it a cow's vagina I
think the crudeness that he Associates
with himself when he like we've learned
that he just that's him and himself
to be self-deprecating it's different
when somebody else says yes yes like
someone else speaking about
it well anyway we were there was lots of
exchanges of words between us so I
thought we were having a friendly
ribbing
and then all of a sudden uh I guess not
all of a sudden I look I I accept my
part in this right like I I missed first
I missed kind of the
the whole point I thought we were hyping
up the podcast and it was going to turn
into this great Bonanza
but um I guess he got offended or maybe
he just said he was offended I honestly
I don't know I did take it too far I
said too much stuff about him though he
did a interview today on oopaville's
Channel
over the weekend and uh yeah this is the
podcast that they created together
yeah
four million Subs that's his main
Channel they created a podcast you just
said yesterday it was it was talking
about the inner the the clip of him
speaking it's on their podcast
thank you Lena wait so where's their
podcast what channel is that it's in the
write-up it's called Uh dumpster fire
so apparently he started a podcast with
uh for a little bit okay
that has 39K Subs currently okay I see
yeah so they they I guess shot one
episode of this podcast and it fell
apart already which is exactly what
happened in front of me so you guys
might actually very well have a hit on
your hands here
right I mean you got well it took a
little longer than one episode to fall
apart in our case no the first step or
was it the second or the third no I
remember the first one was contentious
he takes that fight it was a bit yeah I
mean it wasn't like storm out the show's
over contentious but
well anyway nickato brought me up and I
thought this was long squashed beef
right uh we had actually we had a really
nice pleasant conversation about it for
a little bit at the end of it where both
of us were very nice and cordial and
just like you know I'm sorry it didn't
work out let's maybe try to make it work
out I'm sorry if I have energy or
whatever yada yada
but here he is using me as fodder to
promote his podcast is that what I'm
seeing and of course I always catch
Strays no matter what it was on the
subreddit with a lot of uploads and so
all the comments were like Ethan [ __ ]
this up he was so mean he takes it too
far I'm like damn I already like I
already
laid myself at the altar do we got a
[ __ ] castrate me every time Nick
brings it up
so here he is again
let's listen
okay there's a space right there's a
space already having regrets literally
you are a finicky [ __ ] I will be honest
you are a finicky [ __ ] someone else
wanted to do a podcast with you
oh yeah oh I did I wasn't trying to make
a podcast well he clarifies he clarifies
okay okay by the way he seems like a
nice guy this guy he seems like a guy I
love him seems like a guy seems like a
guy he's a guy I'm not saying I'm not
gonna say a bad word about him which is
good for me that's progress he seems
very nice I'm not that guy
he is that guy
and I don't know why it wasn't wait no
it was a guest it wasn't like start oh
freaking podcast that would be great it
was a guess now but you're telling me
again you're telling me that this is
this dude takes himself seriously that's
what I'm saying like can you really
blame me for reading the room wrong
this man is not
he's not taking himself seriously
he's wearing a shirt from like Kids R Us
and he weighs like 350.
but okay
we'll keep watching
right guess spot and I honestly would
have hi I know you're watching
hi nice to see you again
[Laughter]
how are you it's nice to see you again
Nick I'm glad you're doing well I don't
hold any Grudge and actually I would
love to still do the podcast with you I
would love love love to have you in L.A
anytime
stay in touch
I honestly would have had you not talk
behind my back tell people what I said
in text messages say all these things
that were supposed to be kept private
before I even met you and then attacked
my weight
I stop it with the weight
do I need to pull out again
this man attacked my way Imagine This
this he goes this man attacked my weight
how dare he mention it
well Dan you had some thoughts about
this I
right guess what not about the weight
part but honestly it's high I know
you're watching
I honestly would have
had you not
try my back tell people what I said in
text messages did say all these things
that were supposed to be kept private
before I even met you and yeah so about
that I mean there was no zemblance of I
mean we were talk I don't know I didn't
think it was a problem
you know
pull out Ethan what does that mean
why is everyone spamming pull out Ethan
yeah you said should I should I pull out
so they're running with it I said pull
out pull out yeah
why is that funny
like the pull out I I think like what
like you might just say you might say
pull up I believe because you're like
should I pull up is that you guys
talking about pull out like what uh
Andrew Tate does to Aiden no no the
other kind
and then attack my beat
four-time applied though the weight
things thank you he's a great guy this
guy no everyone does that it doesn't
matter I wasn't even there to defend
myself and he wanted me to drop
everything for him stranger number one
cross country
can I say the name say the name anything
Klein from what podcast they they
they're so funny they know exactly but
you know what what's the name of the
podcast what I appreciate is how they're
self-aware about it yeah you know seems
fine I like it it's funny I got you know
it's funny working it is
the podcast that is going down the tubes
h3h3
unless people are watching less people
are watching and they're all gonna come
over here whoa
foreign
bites yeah oh what a king yeah you
actually synced him up really good so
yeah yeah yeah yeah
the podcast is going on the tubes h3h3
unless people are watching less people
are watching and they're all gonna come
over here oh yeah wow
what I did it like too is that it just
felt this guy is it felt like I was
about to walk into a territory where I'd
be ganged up on it was too many people
too many all eyes on me yeah and here's
the real reason this that's what I was
gonna he was getting anxious which I
totally understand it's a live show he's
coming to a place with a bunch of
strangers in a city he's not used to a
live show everyone was talking about
this podcast anticipating it and so I
understand the nerves being anxious I
get that totally and it just overwhelmed
me you want to pull out but he spun it
like I was like uh this is all my fault
the truth is he just didn't want to do
it anymore I suspect that may be the
case also the part that I said I took
issue with it was all the stuff about
the things that he found offensive about
talking about him
he's totally entitled to feel offended
by that no issue with that when he said
uh asking me to drop everything and fly
across the country
we're flying him out
if I recall correctly he was coming to
La anyways for something else and we he
just extended his stay to come on the
podcast so he wasn't dropping anything
to come on the show
by the way it's like that's that's a
little bit of a
insincere framing it might be we planned
it around his schedule I wasn't like you
have to but by the way we bought him a
non-refundable
first-class tip round trip ticket to La
for a trip he was already planning so
even though he canceled his appearance
on this show he sure [ __ ] enjoyed
those first class tickets to Los Angeles
which we're I don't actually know for a
fact if he used them I just know that we
weren't able to cancel him so he said
feel free to just use the tickets if you
want I don't know if he ever utilized
the tickets or not or was it like a cash
redemption or just here's the tickets
they're yours it was just here's the
tickets because the only because
we didn't get the flight insurance which
in red you know they took it why
wouldn't he I guess he probably did I
just don't know that for facts I
remember seeing him collabing with
someone in La around the time we were
supposed to right and he was he probably
did but unless he took a different trip
I don't know so he he turned out pretty
good he got his ass a free round trip
first class flight
and how much do you remember how much
the tickets were
it was expensive it wasn't as crazy as
you'd think I remember being kind of
shocked that it was like 1500 yeah it
was like that which isn't cheap by any
means but it wasn't a lot of money or
nothing
in that case yeah
what a b are you gonna say something
somebody said oh no don't use them I was
on his flight from ATL to LAX Delta
first class what the [ __ ] that's oh okay
I'll take your word I think that was the
carrier so I actually kind of believe
that dude that's funny how weird that
you happen to be on that flight okay but
um shout out
I'm not mad at him right even though
like it was all good that's real money
but you know it's fine I get it
it was a long shot anyway I was shocked
that we were able to when he committed
to coming here and we'd like I was like
yo this is crazy he's actually coming
here
and uh gonna come on the show so I knew
it was
tenuous personally I think if I was a
total sweetheart and nice or well I am a
total sweetheart I'm a big teddy bear
and with my cow's vagina looking [ __ ]
my fast looks like a cows with John I
could say that
I've been hanging out with Hunger FFF
too much
you're learning oh God but uh if I if I
never talked about him
uh I think he still would have canceled
that's my opinion he was just nervous
it's hard to say but I think
that like you said that that last little
tidbit that he throws in when he's
giving his explanation struck the most
authentic to me
about her being a little anxious but I'm
still here it is an intimidating
environment I've thought about that
before and
with the setup that we have
um you know we always set up the guest
intentionally facing that direction
because otherwise they would just see
all of us sitting here in the control
area and it is a little to just like
have a bunch of people hovering over
well you should get a picture of what
what they would see yeah it's a lot this
control room that they're sitting in is
pretty official crazy looking yeah I'll
do that but I get it like I said I'm not
mad I get it but
yeah ultimately he canceled and used the
[ __ ] first class tickets for to have
a nice holiday
DPI statements everybody wants so this
yeah wow okay
and so you can show just for the
perspective yeah okay ABS babies looks
like a cutout
so here I am
[Music]
hi there's the crew
so it's a big it's a big setup people
it's funny our old podcast people would
come in and say oh it's so much smaller
than I expected
and the new office people always go this
is [ __ ] crazy which I actually much
prefer as a reaction
um
Bradley's still dreaming about it right
now
well maybe I should start a podcast with
Bradley
and Steve will do it and Kyle we'll call
it the milk podcast full sandbox Steve
had some very nice things to say about
you today on bread so no way sweetheart
alert
sweetheart alert such a tender heart and
soul I've always loved him can you time
stamp those I'll finish out this uh NECA
yeah I'll put it at the bottom of this
section oh that's so special we have
such a nice relationship now
it's very sweet I told you guys what he
damned me right tenderhearted
and he's engaged oh congrats to him
congrats
yeah that's that's great news I love
love you know
I think marriage is great
you think it's special and I'm very
happy for him Steve will I do it
whatever move on Steve will put a ring
on it
he will do it
will I do like that as you were saying
did you want to unpack that yeah I think
I just proved that I don't I don't think
before I speak it just comes out there's
no filter Just Go with It the collapsing
into your into your hands was funny
though so you saved it with that thank
you all right let's continue on with uh
Nick ocado interestingly the pit of an
auto avocado looks like his butthole
which is nicer a nicer like uh just a
minute ago I would love to still see
this podcast happen
maybe his name's not necokato I had this
maybe no more talk about it but that's
more flattering than the cow vagina
analogy right it's more flattering but
it's less flattering than not commenting
on his [ __ ] period
but at the same time I do think it's not
that crazy because that's like hunger FF
coming out here and being like I don't
want to talk about my prologue that's
what he does on only fans that's like
his dude anyway whatever I mean I'm
improving avocado pit is a step up so
let's not baby steps then don't expect
too much of me
can you do a DPI thing the people are
losing their minds
I don't like your fault no I won't do
the DPI thing Dan's putting his foot
down he's too much guy fans like it's
funny but we can't overdo it
just give them one
800 DPI that was a good that was a
smooth one the 800. that's a perfect
number you could tell how calm I
measured he was
[Music]
Nick ocado bro it's in the name
I could have said it looks like a whole
avocado
which would be Mars because it's bigger
what's the perfect size for that like a
grape
maybe not even that huh probably like a
raisin what an [ __ ] yeah
um although the one who's in the I mean
it's subjective yeah what are you into
you're into tighter tighter or gate
he's got a nice little b-hole that looks
like a just stop stop
I was trying to be nice are you trying
to be nice yeah I was trying to be
[ __ ] I was trying to be complimentary
looks like a nerd the size of a nerd can
do and it's beautiful it's very little
sour a little sweet yes that's Sour
Patch
the sour patch the slogan is first or
sour then they're sweet oh okay I don't
think they get the ownership of that Dan
or someone please tell Ethan that Joe
Rogan is related to Jared oh yeah we
know that from Chemical Romance they're
cousins isn't that so weird we learned
that lore from Trisha and yes and by the
way they have they're not in
communication
they're first cousins that they don't
talk apparently are they first cousins
first cousins okay
huh
how crazy is that
talented family I guess
but they're so different like
My Chemical Romance like emo right
they're in Nemo Ben yeah I don't think
anyway about that because I don't let's
get back to Nick who's got a beautiful
little B hole that looks and tastes like
a nerd
candy it's Gerard by the way yeah
distant cousins I'm saying not first oh
well yeah I didn't think too I remember
there was a clip of Joe saying we're
first cousins
don't whatever it wouldn't be the first
time Joe's been wrong
you'd think he would know that
like too is that it just felt I felt I
felt like I was about to walk into it
she thought he was just holding really
still it's frozen for some reason
oh the screen froze yeah
[Music]
Gerard sorry Gerard
a hot Gerald not Jared
Gerald Gerard
um
foot long foot long Gerard are we good
we're good okay cool
territory where I be ganged up on
there's too many people too many all
eyes on me yeah and
from the get-go break breaching
confidentiality before I even get it
there's no calm okay so confident [ __ ] I
mean I'm like you know what I'm not
gonna go through this that's a big stink
about a year ago I remember seeing it it
was a big it was a big thing he made a
big deal about it of course he did yeah
he made like oh and like Nick didn't
he didn't make a as big of a deal as you
did dude he put a [ __ ] video behind
his a bit of one video how many videos
did we make
huh
how long did we stretch out the drama
for Content but for free I don't know
that's what I'm saying he's
I don't know
videos about it and I made one I would
never do after the fact
huh yeah there's an IMDb page for the
real reason nicocado avocado canceled
the H3 podcast a web page IMDb page four
oh my god really well does it say the
truth because a lot of these websites
LIE there's websites that say I'm five
seven it just says like how tall he's
tall he's over six foot yeah at least
six there's websites that say I'm worth
like millions of dollars you're not
there's websites that say that
yeah
I'm sorry but Nick is crazy ask comedic
timing he's really funny I know no doubt
I thought we were doing schnick yeah I
think that it's it really did make me
sad honestly watching this because I
think that you guys would be hilarious
it would have been a very funny
interview yeah I thought it would be
great yeah oh
look he's giving you guys the look
so is this it by the way is there more
that's it that's it that's pretty much
it yeah yeah and also the IMDb page is
just the name of the episode that
happens all the time it's just like Auto
through Google so you know uh Nick if
that is your real name
uh I'm here
still waiting you are always welcome
and to the guy who made the podcast
love you Super Trooper
great guy funny guy terrific guy tender
heart tenderhearted just like Steve will
do it let's talk about him
we love you you're very special
um where is it here or where is it baby
it's right here it's highlighted uh
right under the section what number is
it
um
I just see it says Elon beautiful I
don't see it oh right here
that was you just pasted that right I'm
not crazy yeah okay
so Brad think Steve will do a talk about
me more this is on their official Nook
podcast no this is on Bradley's podcast
the separate
you could hear like a weird breathing is
that cam
I care and that is not me I just unmuted
I keep hearing
[Music]
no all right nevermind
yeah honestly we have a lot of questions
for Donnie I went on eight Street spot
we were talking about us coming on the
Pod yeah yeah H3 H3 we're actually we
actually made up what happened whoa I
saw that clip I saw clips of your
podcast yep
but not for the reasons
we did the where he's not he didn't do
it Andy's ripping a guard dude yeah he's
living up to the hype man
called me after and you're like oh H3
he's a pretty solid guy he's just kind
of I guess it's his thing to you know go
after people that's what he did yeah and
you know what it's hard to explain I
feel like
I'm just sometimes I just take [ __ ] too
far you know what I mean it's just it's
not like it's not my thing by Design I'm
just
I just get carried away and sometimes uh
it sucks because you
you actually
Burning Bridges with people that you're
not really because they come out and
they go I [ __ ] hate that guy I'm like
damn
that sucks because I I'm not trying to
have like beef with them
what happened to his leg look at that
[ __ ]
took a beater there didn't it
sound like a big old bump it looks like
a huge bruise or something yeah what
happened Steve hit me up
talk about it but he does right honestly
H3 you know when I lived with Ernie
Ernie was my best friend and he actually
really liked H3 and I would always hang
out with Ernie so I remember watching H3
with Ernie and you know I like them
because you know I was like my best
buddy likes him so yeah I just like them
so I it was never meant for us to hate
each other no I feel like no but after
watching the podcast to you guys and
then you telling me that yeah he's a
pretty good guy I was like [ __ ] it you
know make up with him yes I messaged him
I was like hey sorry about what I said
about you and your wife which you know
uncalled for talking about anyone's wife
is of course yeah uncalled for
um it's okay bro and yeah he really
appreciated it because I saw another
podcast clip and he was like actually he
was really sweet of Steve or however he
said it was really kind it actually
meant a lot and this and that so I'm
glad we made up I'm glad I won't have
him talking [ __ ] about me now I want to
talk [ __ ] about him well just put it
just hey I didn't make that for her
laughs
you know what you know what I like I
liked a lot about going doing that
podcast the thing that I think is really
important and special like that we kind
of are starting to lose just in general
in general as a society is like even
though some people believe different
things like whether it be like
politically or like just just opinions
about life in general like it's cool to
be able to sit down with someone and
still have a conversation that can be
productive for for both sides and I
think I think we've kind of lost that a
little bit on social media nowadays
where it just seems like if you don't
believe what someone else believes and
you're like the enemy and you're the
wrong person or you're not right because
like I'm right and they're wrong and I
just think it's like we've got to a
point where like we need to start trying
to preach uh is this all worth watching
or I mean I'm down to watch it all but
if we you know what I mean that's pretty
much it just that's pretty much it yeah
that is the biggest full scent I've ever
seen wow that's full circle base that's
a double stand full circle
you know and he is so he's a sweetheart
I'm very happy for him and Donnie as
well uh and his beautiful bride uh who's
seems by all accounts to be a great gal
Bradley is such a sweetheart too he came
we had a great time he's out there you
know he's writing for him he's speaking
kindly which I appreciate you know it's
really nice to see it spread the good
word
I really do want to make up with the
whole manosphere stuff you know there's
like the Fallen fan
category is a big [ __ ] category oh
yeah it's like everyone like everyone
really everyone but I used to watch your
videos yeah it's true
so I'd like to have Steve on I think
it'd be fun I think it'd be interesting
and actually I'm here to announce where
our starting a podcast together with
Kyle and uh that other dude that's on
their podcast steiny stymie and this is
another dude right
all right maybe if they're going to
change all of them they're all joining
yeah we're gonna make a podcast together
we call it the full send featuring Ethan
Klein Now podcast and uh it's gonna be
huge it's gonna be the next biggest
thing oh wow also my shareholder and
happy Dad now one of the main players
there so thank you
sick oh by the way through a makeup
episode with Steve and Nick acato
simultaneously wow get them both in here
see that's a crossover that I think
people would like that'd be such insane
genuinely that would be a fire content
and there's no reason that shouldn't
happen a sick episode would be someone
from every like corner of YouTube and
like bring them all in and try to have
the most civilized conversation
my godfather
it's the bleeding of the bosses oh the
bosses the five families today the five
families have come together
to do the Kim Kardashian makeup tutorial
2019.
as you well know that was the best
makeup tutorial
James Charles was popping off
Jeffree Star the world was crazy about
these tutorials the bottom line is you
cannot be trusted and now we all sit
here today to create a peace between the
great families
[Music]
turtleneck goes well with the whole Don
look
if I do say so myself thank you you're
welcome yeah I love these guys they're
investing material I'll join them for
agar we should get a gar I'll bring my
dog he can sit in my lap
maybe it'd be a good old time no it's a
way don't bring the dogs I mean I know
we we now believe that we're pretty sure
he didn't but maybe not bring the dogs
out yeah it still seems like a risky
that's like the thing to put your dog in
that position you know
that's interesting point
I mean 90 from the poll did say they
think he did I know I know and there's I
know and I'm not saying that he didn't
no he didn't he did right yeah it's it's
fine but it's like OJ writing his book
if I did it you know
if I did it
I'm not saying I did do it okay whatever
thank you by the way we got a donation
from
Nick's co-host
Ville did we really yeah
so he's out there what's up player we
love you was there a message yeah he
says come to Texas and do our pod Nick
is fuming
he's turning red with anger and rage
wait wait wait does Nick doesn't live in
Texas though does he like how do you all
do that show together uh I they were
talking about how we flew there and they
just filmed another video for his main
channel right so maybe he's shot guns
and stuff dude they got a nice thing
going on there it's pretty cool good for
you guys Hoopa if you're still watching
and watched a bit of uh your latest
video where you had him shoot the big
machine gun it was very funny enjoying
it they got like a good almost like a
Frenemies Dynamic going on there they do
yeah it's nice
um enjoy it and nobody's ever compared
Nick to uh Trisha before
nobody's ever made that comparison
um if I I when I come out to Texas I
mean come on you do you guys have kids
do you guys have you know do five
episodes a week why I gotta find a
babysitter he's tired I'm not gonna have
a babysitter on that day
from the first Jew on stage longest day
ever
of course Ryan Kavanaugh is such a
[ __ ] loser play that again in the
first Jew on stage in Texas what a
banger man
see what's funny
yeah
um he just said I love you guys are you
doing another 20.
actually I love you too dude and
congratulations on the success of all
your content with Nick it's great love
to see it
um
but yeah you guys should come out here
maybe you guys come out together
off but you I'll put Nick in first class
in you and Coach is that okay
uh Jennifer says I want Trixie on the
podcast that's something we're working
on we're trying yeah we're working on it
all right so moving on let's talk about
Elon Musk taking the fattest l in human
history holy [ __ ] yeah I'm just
you know I've turned on Elon big time as
a lot of people have
I just returned my Tesla
let's go
the first totally support that the first
nice car I ever got
was a Tesla Model S a long-ass time ago
right when they were still kind of a
fresh thing drove that for three years
then we got an X drove that for three
years just returned it
you know I was pretty dedicated but
I swapped it out
and I'll tell you for sure that's the
last Tesla I'm going to be driving
yeah I mean at least for now and by the
way while he's in charge which might not
be the case another year or two from now
I don't think Tesla's Gonna Last because
the BMW that we leased
which is the oh yeah AB says he's had a
cyber truck Reserve me too they just
stole [ __ ] 100 bucks yeah everyone
told you that at the time in fact I
think I did like can we get it back I
don't know there was a time when I think
you could but I I think that program's
over that's got to be illegal yeah it
seems very questionable I saw people
canceling their their orders yeah I do
believe there was there was a window to
uh withdraw your pre-order but I think
you're you're locked in now so
that's fraud bro I need evidence that
you guys are actually making it it was
supposed to come out like three years
ago now yeah right wasn't it like 2019
is when you could reserve and I think
it's supposed to come out 2020. so two
years two years behind schedule well
it's almost three years now yeah by the
way quick little preview for you guys
the me and the boys
uh ripping darts
smoking bars tearing it up oh you gotta
use that photo Ethan you gotta do them
dirty like that they're Maga but I have
a bigger Mega hat all out mag of their
ass in fact when I go on their podcast
I'm gonna wear my giant bag at just to
show that actually would be pretty funny
that I support them okay
yeah so Elon Musk yeah so I got the BMW
now and I know we had a conversation
about it love you almost talked her out
of it
yeah I mean I I think it's a good car
technique technologically but I think
the like user experience is pretty bad
yeah
so I don't know if that's the 2022 we
have the 23 one whatever but I love this
car it is so nice
the battery
yeah yeah yeah I love my BMW all
electric
it drives so nice the battery has a
bigger charge the charging stations are
frankly better than the Tesla ones my
car charged so [ __ ] fast we stopped
went to the bathroom got snacks came
back we went from 20 to like 65 in just
a few minutes just a few minutes wow
it's not impressive it's nuts so if you
didn't go to a Tesla charging station
you just go to a generic electric EV
charger position yeah yeah yeah yeah and
everyone else bought Tesla is making
Universal plugs like you know obviously
and so everyone it's just like apple
yeah like we got it we gotta have our
own plug
so stupid
um and so everybody
everyone's using the same charger it's
called Electrify America and it's so
fast it's so good
and so I'm out and I'm and what I think
is going to happen is there's more
competition I think Tesla's not going to
be able to pull their weight once the
competition gets up and it's happening
fast
by the way morgpai donates she says hey
Ethan I just want to say we decided to
get health insurance thank God I was so
worried about you I've been I've been
thinking about you good call
you know I just been thinking about you
I've just been so worried I'm just
kidding I'm glad to hear that I'm just
playing into the bit everyone's being
everyone said you're my hall pass and I
assured
there's we don't play that there's no
Hall Pass there's no help there's no
Hall
that's a good way but you know what I
mean there's no Hall not even walking
I'm staying I'm staying though hall
there's no pass
no pass
okay anyways but I'm glad you did that's
great I'm really glad happy for you good
good call
uh
um so yeah let's watch these clips so
Chappelle was doing a show in San
Francisco
and I what I assume is happening is that
him and Elon Musk are buddies
because they both are like we're cool
we're important let's chat uh they've
been like photoed together before I
believe yeah them and Joe Rogan yeah
with Rogan and stuff and like yeah the
thing is like
the type Elon Musk is not cool in any
way it's like this weird fetishization
of of this extraordinarily well wealth I
mean he is like a king right modern day
King
and we're like a like a powerful Duke
yeah not a king
he's a Duke some the Duke of the turd oh
got him dude Duke of turd dude
thank you and uh
uh and so
he's buddy Chappelle who's this great
comedian there's nothing less funny than
becoming besties with Elon Musk who's by
all accounts the one one of the best
people to satirize in our society today
he's making a public spectacle of him of
himself he treats his workers like [ __ ]
like he's known for trading workers like
[ __ ] being anti-union and um yet here
you are
being so buddied up with him that he
invited him he said come up come with me
Backstage on the show and join me on
stage for what reason what was his goal
I'm sincerely confused by it I genuinely
think Elon or I think Chappelle thought
Elon was this absolute force that
everyone was just going to lose their
mind be this great moment
but there's no plan and and Chappelle
just leaves him out there too he's like
he could have been like all right thanks
he says hi he goes but he left his house
out there taking tomatoes for like 10
minutes it's brutal it was crazy and you
know I think they're friends and stuff
and he wanted to do a nice moment for
Elon but what happened is Chappelle
actually subjected him to like a mass
public flogging
and Chappelle also looks terrible
yeah it was big unintentionally based
but Chappelle also looks like a [ __ ]
hack you know yeah big time well and
what he said is worse than anything Elon
said once he was up there
which part I mean we're going to watch
it but we're gonna watch it I'll open it
up they're the canceled besties yeah
but it's like dude
it's just that relationship is so
unfunny
yeah I'm I'm homies with the richest man
in the world and on the weekends I hang
out with Bill Gates and Jeff Bezos we're
all dogs
anyway let me joke about Society
trans people
yeah that's what he means [ __ ] trans
people anyway uh trans people are the
big problem in society anyway let's go
let's go um
take a yacht Elon
let's go take a a yacht to Epstein's
Island
okay whatever there he is so here it is
uh and so the rumor is
now Chappelle he has a policy
where he doesn't allow people to film
him live
so somebody posted this on Twitter
and the word on the street is that it
was removed
yeah uh that turns out to have been
pretty thoroughly debunked I think okay
yeah because people are like oh Elon
what a what a coward he's like censoring
this or whatever and I was already
suspicious of that because it was like
all over Twitter and it's like why would
the leading one well just rebut that
once it's kind of uh because it's out
there there's no point the the uh the
debunking was that people thought that
um that account uh uh had it deleted or
was banned for posting that
um the wording of the error message that
comes up when you pull up the account is
what it shows when somebody deactivates
their account and so what I think is
much more likely is they posted it and
they were getting the musk Fanboys
jumping down his throat scary exactly
like legitimately like probably we'll
get death threats you know what it
probably happened would be would be
enough to scare just like an ordinary
citizen into deleting it is like Dave
Chappelle is going to sue you you leaked
he knows who you are right you're like
oh [ __ ] I don't want to exactly so I
believe that they just uh pulled the
plug but people had already ripped it it
was all over YouTube at that point it's
out so
um but yeah I don't think musk went out
of his way to to try and delete it off
the internet yeah Chappelle hating trans
people and hanging out with billionaires
is like the least funny [ __ ] ever
yeah
someone commented Chappelle's a huge
divider for people in their 30s either
you love them still or you hate them or
you think he's a devil now yeah and I
think that's true I mean it's tough like
I said on a previous spot like for me
it's just he's just a disappointment
it's like what it's not funny you're
just you used to be funny
yeah and making fun of marginalized
groups and being besties trying to
whitewash Elon Musk is like sad [ __ ]
you're a boot licker and that is the
thing it's like you know I'll give more
space I'm not so sensitive to the
you can't joke about those things at all
or whatever but I think that last
special that he did in particular like
that whole series of specials that he
did on Netflix where it was causing all
the controversy in the first one it was
like a 10 minute bit that he did on like
trans people or whatever that got him in
some hot water and then the second one
because he got hot water for it he
turned it into like a 30 minute bit by
the last one it was like the whole
special and it's not even a comedy
special anymore it's just him like
bitching for an hour I can't say is all
about like fro I can't say anything yeah
it's like there was a couple jokes and
even every once in a while some of them
were funny but it just legitimately
it wasn't a good comedy special bro we
talked about it when it happened for me
it's like it's just not funny and I see
you're doing the same material now yeah
like I get it man it's been years it's
just years of the like the one topic
that you talk about it's just I thought
it was super weird how he like tokenized
his trans friend who like had unalived
herself I forget all the details of that
but that did seem very gross what he was
trying to how he was trying to spin that
I had one trans friend so y'all don't
know what you're talking about
uh anyway whatever that's that's now
here now there here's the clip what is
here and there but we're over it so
here's the clip
I Think You're Gonna Make some noise for
the richest man in the world
so again that's like that's the value
that's what he sees him he's the richest
man in the world
and that alone merits adoration
I guess I mean I'm sure a lot of people
do think that so
[Music]
but Dave Chappelle's supposed to be like
more
nuanced than that
[Applause]
this is where this is what you become
raw like it's so great he's literally
just getting booed imagine just like two
years ago what a different like if this
exact thing happened two years ago love
just like thunderous Applause it'd be
kind of random
I may be random but like I don't think
there was that neg I loved him degree of
that I mean lots of people loved him and
even if you didn't it would just be oh
that's cool oh Elon Musk of all people
he's here like you know what I mean I
mean Dave usually brings people out
randomly so I feel like sure yeah
yeah and he just cut I think he's just
trying to riff and create a moment but
well
so
confirmed or not but people in chat were
saying that Hassan said
um that he was trying to get his friend
unbanned on Twitter
say what for what I don't know that's
just what wait what are you talking
about that that's why he brought Elon
out Chappelle was trying to get a friend
a personal friend of his okay that's a
theory that's going that um how can he
know that they're homies he just say yo
I'm being my friend why we'd have to
bring him out on stage uh yeah I don't
know
well I'll tell you what if that was his
motive his friend staying banned it
didn't work not getting any favors after
this
[Applause]
oh there is no articles about this
everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the tomatoes
for a collection
we're expecting this for you
he wasn't expecting me you weren't
expecting me
to be the victim of hate crimes he's
like yeah you see what it's like to be
me
that's me it's so difficult I tried to
tell you
are in the audience
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I can't even continue respect the uh
the determination of boohoo's ass
incredible unrelenting no so awesome the
people that did that legitimately like
public shaming of billionaires should be
far more common you see that video of
Bill Gates getting up high in the face
yeah we were just talking about it yeah
earlier today yeah but that was back in
the day when before he was like
universally hated or maybe he was hated
back then I don't know someone pied him
in the face so hard the the news
coverage of it too was kind of like
propaganda in that they were like this
cowardly uh attempt from Hitmen to come
to hit man yeah yeah I got it home it
was a poisoned pie yeah
they just creampied him in the face
North Korea should start assassinating
people like that just put some crazy ass
nerve agent in a pie so that they
actually die for me to hide in the face
it'd be awesome way to go
quite a way to go
um
what is this
that's the pie in the face you gotta
hear the lead up to it though can I
watch this you think it's fine right
it's just a pie in the face yeah but you
got to hear the the intro that's the
timestamp medium first with a pie in the
face
dude the follow through on that was
super impressive
that was a banger pie to the face man
the target was Microsoft chairman by the
way I'm not in favor of anything like
this
that I mean this is physical violence I
know it's a pie in the face but you're
still hitting someone it's not good
rates arriving for a meeting with
Community leaders watch what happens
when a team of Hitmen medium purse with
a pie in the face
[Applause]
you probably thought it was something
else yeah it's disorienting they're just
like come out of nowhere pretty crazy
yeah I don't support that I disavow this
in the greatest terms possible it's not
cool it's not funny we disavow this
right Dan uh Ian throw it up
oh do we have one here
throw it up
here we'll watch it again but with the
disavow so the extra disavowed okay here
we go this is a dis extra disavow with
peace and love we just about pies to the
face we disavowed this is Criminal this
is horrific act of violence and we
disavow this from the strongest
this is me disavowing absolutely peace
and love I want to tell you please after
December December 13th no more pies in
the face thank you thank you I have some
long gone goodbye
according to SF Gate Chappelle asked
Moss if he could unban quali from social
media platform with reporter Gabe lemon
writing quali was standing five feet
away from musk during the request so the
Twitter CEO didn't have much choice but
to Greece so wait who is this guy he's
uh he's a rapper he's a rapper
harassing specifically one woman but
there were previous instances on Twitter
of him harassing women and um
was he unbanned not yet there you go
it's at the end of the article it said
we don't know what's going to happen not
after those booze that's what I'm saying
maybe he's Perma band for now Dave's
about to be banned I guess Elon isn't
for free speech after all
Shredder's cold
oh poor guy yeah I didn't mention about
the kids are super sick like both of
them are so sick no we got home and
Bruce was like he didn't even smile when
he saw us he was just like so out of it
crazy fever scary
uh he's doing better today though and he
puke he was like puking last night every
time we try to give him medicine he
would puke it out I was really worried
yesterday we uh me and Lena just stopped
by to drop something off at your house
before you guys got back and Theodore
and Donna were there and uh Elizabeth
was telling Theodore he has to clean the
living room and he looks up at her and
goes I'm sick
it's smart kid yeah it's so cute
he's smart he knows
[Music]
uh rack and it here so driving 30 hours
one way for the live show wow with my
puppy so excited to see y'all can't wait
for everybody in the audience
to restrict their sound bites we're all
brainwashed thank you peace and love
all right let's continue
[Music]
[Music]
they have terrible seats I don't
understand
last minute
now I'm playing a [ __ ] blue
the worst approach right because first
of all it's not coming from the back and
second of all the you know what the
cheapest tickets cost the the ones he
says oh these four [ __ ] who hate rich
people I guess 300 bucks
was the cheapest ticket these people
[ __ ] paid to watch his ass
look at you poor [ __ ]
Elon Musk is worth a million of this
Stadium
foreign I believe it was closer to 200
but still 200 oh yeah okay
[Music]
Chappelle's Berlin come back
put in the context here we go we got
context we're breaking this down guys
Chappelle's brilliant come back here
Best comedian live even still some
people insist should be put into the
context at the cheapest seats for the
show
were 176 dollars
the only ones that remained are under
200 so okay that's what I said kind of
yo wait what
this is what it looked like
why does it look so [ __ ] empty
The show must have not started right
what this is empty there's no way
yeah this must have been
why is everyone crowding at the front
the pit yeah the pit might be a GM this
is definitely yeah this is before
there's no way dude look how empty it is
I'm sure he sells out stadiums oh yeah
okay all right let's watch
[Applause]
listen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ing is not even trying to die on Earth
and I love how Elon doesn't even know
what to do Chappelle's not helping him
at all he's just standing there and he's
already awkward he asked him at one
point Dave what do I do yeah he's he
wants to get out of there
his whole business model is [ __ ] Earth
I'm leaving anyway
[Music]
s
whatever kind of person they got up
there that's what we'll be doing
Andy gravity titty bars follow their
dreams bitching the money just flow all
over the road
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
I wouldn't miss this opportunity
the first comedy club on Mars that
should be mine a deal
for us
hello yeah
foreign
he bought me a jet pack for Christmas oh
yeah not even a joke though it's funny
he's like he could do a lot for me
these nuts
and [ __ ]
he's sitting too elon's got to stand
there while he sits
don't say nothing okay it'll only spoil
the moment do you hear that sound Elon
that's the sound of the pending she's
still unrest
that's the sound of the people that will
string you up Elon and decapitate you in
the street isn't that funny I don't know
what he's trying to do here is he trying
to comfort him that's the sound of
people that will come into your home at
night's a hug tie you
to arm feather you that they're not
happy out there Elon they're suffering
and they paid 200 to come watch this
[ __ ]
in fact get extra security tonight Elon
right next [ __ ]
oh
[Music]
you sure
[Music]
I wish everybody in this Auditorium
peace
and the joy of feeling free this is so
crazy like he's literally he hasn't said
[ __ ] it's five minutes in yeah literally
he goes everybody feels free and his
like big thing is that he's really
prejudice against trans people not you
not you everyone else though not like
that not like that's not what I meant
um but God he's put Iman into the most
awkward situation probably of his life
and he's just using him like a prop it's
kind of Epic actually yeah
of this
amen thank you very much
good Elon great job bud
as you can just funnier when you saying
you ready
[Music]
wait
dude they [ __ ] set him up here we go
[Applause]
first of all what's so bad
oh so bad
you know it didn't even sound like the
thing
hey you guys his wine his physical
Wind-up to it is what gets me yeah it's
a beautiful dance
you know what I think
here let me type in you guys tell me if
this is funny or if I shouldn't say it
no it's probably not no well no well
here let me I'll type it
real I'm just confirm I'm just
Consulting
Dan get a disavow ready yeah I'm typing
it up
well hold on read it first so I'm going
to the I'm going to you guys I just
typed the joke
yeah definitely not nope that would be
uh really not good yeah no okay because
I was really close to saying
I'm proud of you though for messaging
first that's yeah that's improving yeah
hey
but I'm I'm almost confused that you
guys think it's so bad well I'll explain
it to you after the show
because it's kind of like you know
putting it on up on its head in a way
yeah yeah I think just curious exactly
two I felt it was risky I felt it wasn't
hateful it was risky
well whatever it is I asked
so that was good I felt like um
but yeah it just doesn't seem that bad
to me
what do you think cam did you read it I
basically no I definitely think it's
enough [ __ ] I think I think there's a
million jokes in your head and you can
just move on to the next one you know
what I mean damn that's crazy I I really
genuinely thought like it was funny I'm
I'm usually one to toe the line but I
think it's not worth it okay let me ask
you this is it funny
uh I I don't know I don't think I would
like not even really really I mean I see
what you're doing but yeah but the
audience doesn't know what we're talking
about they have no idea but it's I'm
sure it's interesting I'm sure they're
dying to know but you guys will not ever
know uh that won't go into the graveyard
breaking news Ethan has learned his
lesson and asked first
King
Ethan did anyone think it was funny back
here I need to know
exactly I don't even get it you don't
even get it I
now people saying post it on Twitter no
no no no no no definitely not
Ian was it funny at least Zach you guys
can Ian well
Dean's funny he's got a good sense of
humor
um
Zach you can admit it it's funny
oh wow even a video Ethan for holding
back I just want to say Happy 37th
birthday yeah 37 baby
hey what happened did I just age
backwards because I asked well you're
losing it
people are gonna think it's way worse
than it is tonight every time you do
something good it's not it's just not
worth it it's not worth it okay you got
a million better jokes in your mind
thought it was funny
[Music]
yeah so he's gonna have to live with
that moment forever I don't think you
could find someone to do a worse I'm
rich [ __ ] too it's
yeah also not such a softball and he
he's still missed I don't know also not
funny when you are the richest person in
the world
right
I underpay and discriminate and don't
let my workers unionize
[ __ ]
[Applause]
Twitter for like 47 billion in cash
he hits a diva pose when he pulls the
mic up and it it hurts a little bit yeah
it's so bad he looks like he's like the
wind up looks like he's a pitcher in the
World Series wait let's go back and
watch the wind up
sometimes it's okay to say no Elon you
know what I mean like just say no looks
like he's in like bottom of the ninth
like he's winding it up man like about
to throw a strike on my life seriously
you look angry are you angry that I even
suggested it down no okay not at all
we're proud we're proud of you yeah good
thank you guys Ethan Klein everybody
let's give Ethan a round of applause
that's our bus even you should try that
okay what I'm rich [ __ ] yeah I just did
it
I missed it wind it up
[Laughter]
trying to read what's up
trying to read what's on elon's shirt it
says Twitter or something I think it
says Twitter is awesome yes it does he's
the first one to say that
even listen you can't convince anyone of
that I don't care Jordan Peterson knows
that it's a rattle or a hole the
Butter's a rat best steak he ever had
rats will dance for money if you hate
them what I'm not sure about that one
Jordan
there it is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
did Elon just like come from a dental
procedure like is his mouth numb is that
why he can't uh say rich
[Music]
quality is the rapper so he really
trying to get his friend on band
[Music]
she's a customer service because there's
no one left he does everything he goes
he goes uh what did you do well I
stalked I threatened women I may have
leaked uh sexual content of them uh the
revenge porn he's like great that's well
we'll take care of it as long as you
didn't impersonate me yeah foreign
bite gold could it be a contender I
don't know let's see what happens we
don't have a lot of time it's a late
late yeah I've only like two days
[Music]
where's your phone listen
years ago this is true I'll tell you two
quick Twitter scores
I went to log on to Twitter
I put my name in yeah whatever right
yeah whatever okay whatever so there's
some funny actually follow-ups so this
story starts spreading like wildfire I
mean this thing is viral and then this
is the also the weird little side story
about the account being deleted which
everybody picked up on it
uh I I believe that that he deactivated
to do it yeah anyway Elon commented
about it
which is [ __ ] awesome and this wait
why does it look like that this tweet is
now deleted
dude that's so embarrassing for him he
said what was the comment the guy
omnihedge what did he I just basically
bought him being booed I forget exactly
what it was but I could he said
technically it was 90 cheers and 10
booze except during quiet periods but
still that's a lot of booze which is the
first time for me in real life frequent
on Twitter it's almost as if I've
offended sf's unhinged leftists but nah
that's like crazy copium bro yeah and
the Marvel Universe technically he's
like well no no no most of the people
there liked me it was just like the
unhinged leftists that were booing me
the Dave Chappelle the professional
comedian had to stop what he was doing
the far left activists that were um
attending a Dave Chappelle Show in uh
2022. yeah I don't think there's any far
leftists left in his audience I mean far
left is let's be real just the poor
people I'm back if you're thinking about
like the quartering-esque purple haired
2016.
whatever the [ __ ] you guys think of far
left is uh yeah
so yeah this is him like no oh actually
uh the mo the vast majority of people
are really like me it's just the uh uh
10 uh technically
how do you what do you mean technically
[ __ ] did you do a head count
how do you know how many people were
booing and cheering this is the average
Dave Chappelle fan right here this is
the people in the very back who spent
200 on a ticket yeah yeah
that's funny
oh dude I told man we called this I said
I said buying Twitter is going to ruin
his life yeah it's gonna ruin him
oh no Rory the mofolk are proud of your
restraint you think yes
shout out to the mole folks thank you
Rory
uh wasn't there more uh coping
there was
n't there more coping on Twitter from uh
Elon not really I mean no the the 90 one
was like the the real cringe one yo but
he erased it isn't it yes yes just
imagine like the the absolute blow to
your self-esteem it would take to come
to this tweet and then erase it to
realize how [ __ ] dumb you look that
by clicking delete that's like a week
maybe year ending self-esteem damage
you know sometimes you take a hit so
hard it lasts this is one of those hits
yeah kneecapped
so there he is
Elon and Chappelle BFFs
love that
uh that's basically it I thought I wish
he had more coping I thought there was
more I mean he did tweet of a couple
other things about it but that was the
only one that was like oh well I want to
see what else did you get did he tweet
about it okay
did he say I uh give you money give to
you
I'm gonna wrap it up though because
Shredder's shaking he's really cold oh
yeah even with this little sweater how
long we've been going I mean about three
hours yeah we did our we did our
our duties we did our duties God he
tweets so much like I'm just like
scrolling like everyone dude he doesn't
do anything but just tweet all day it's
the Jordan Peterson syndrome it's crazy
he comments like looks great on a bunch
of stuff like show me what you actually
think dude this is like a phenomenon
like a truck the Donald Trump phenomenon
like he's the first person that spent so
much time on Twitter in a super high
level job that you're like you're not
working at all like if you if you owned
a business and you saw one of your
employees tweeting this Bunch you'd be
like bro you're not working yeah and
imagine if that person was like your
your vice president of production or
like a really high level job that
[ __ ] is definitely getting fired
perfect
and now you see Elon doing it you got it
Jordan Peterson doing it
that [ __ ] is so funny are you still
scrolling Dan yeah I'm I'm in the region
now I'm just looking for any that were
relevant to that it's hard to determine
what's meant to be related to that
because it's also vague and all about
leftists and Bots and [ __ ] yeah it's
hard to tell what's what I love that the
angry leftists in San Francisco
all right that's it I guess so this
right so to on Wednesday tomorrow
tomorrow yes
wait is that Stavros yes it is crazy
that's exciting so Stavros
the very funny comedian actually we've
been trying to get him in here I'm glad
he's coming in already on Wednesday
and then Thursday's leftovers and then
Friday we got this sound bite Olympics
yes sir and we should say leftovers
we're doing the long ask for uh
follow-up to our uh speak to your Magda
family on Thanksgiving we're doing
thanks to you or speak to your mega
family
during the whole we got specials on
specials yep and then next week
the live shows on
Tuesday so we're having a Regular Show
on Monday which is what uh we're not oh
we just have one episode next week Yep
this is the last week of normal shows
and then next week we have our grand
finale and that's y'all are not going to
want to miss that because we're doing
Craigslist we got all the specials it's
gonna be super freaking cool man yes
indeed live wow we're almost done with
the year almost done it's a couple more
episodes
yeah but don't don't despair guys I will
still be doing members content
um also you guys are going to be putting
members content up too right uh we're
gonna try it we're we're so busy
prepping for this live show this week
because we were gonna maybe try and
pre-record something for over the break
this week but uh no pressure you guys
are busy yeah we're we're a little slam
I'm gonna do it yeah and one thing I
want to do is try to get a behind the
scenes of the live show and try to get a
lot of the fans Who come out in that
video so oh that'll be fun yeah by the
way it is free people asking us free
it's just a normal episode we're putting
on a mega production that we're able to
do thanks to people buying tickets we're
using all that money to put on a
fantastic show for everybody it's gonna
be a live stream uh it's gonna look and
sound great I mean knock on wood but
we're planning on doing a nice big thing
there for everyone everybody asking
about oh yes what happened to Steamers
we we always do that in January yeah
it's always a startup comeback show I
like that the steamies we'll be back
with um
Ethan look alike if nothing else comes
through and Ethan looked like in a Phil
look-alike Shelby you can look like host
take the day off okay
can we get a Dan look like
can I take it out oh yeah it's me we
need a higher competency
yeah oh by the way really quick uh the
chest boxing thing that we went to
um one person came up to me and they
said oh my God I love you Dan like is
that a joke at this point or no Olivia
saw it right it was not even a joke were
you there so interesting a girl came up
to me and said you have such a small
face and I said what what that's weird
that's a compliment and I was like okay
thank you first of all you don't have a
small face thank you and I just find
that comment odd okay I was just
confused yeah don't worry it's not I
just want to comfort you people saying
hunger FF could be my lookalike
yeah yeah
what if instead of like hands on the
keyboard and stuff like you do he just
slaps his prolapse on the keyboard that
takes a degree of accuracy that I don't
even know if he has I know he's the goat
I think he could do it but
and shame on you for doubting him
yeah okay well we got a lot of great
shows left guys so happy holidays we're
getting there it's going to be such a
fun closeout I'll probably be making I'm
not promising but there's a good chance
I'll be making Ethan Klein videos
but that you know just for fun or
whatever people are saying Brittany
Broski is your coach for the streamings
maybe if she's around available that
could that'd be great we'll see I think
that's a good idea
um
all right guys we'll see you tomorrow
with stavi baby Stavros
Stavros
very funny very good
I love you all see you tomorrow
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]